roll hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
to see how your week's going you know um
and obviously you're watching this which
means I have a special guest which we do
from time to time um this guy's been
doing it I don't know how long you've
been doing it but in my world this guy
this guy's one of the upand cominging
kids here going to come up and grab the
brass ring I did uh I did the ring with
him on Comedy Central right is that what
that came out was it on the Food Network
I can't remember and he's got a great
new special out uh called progression
please welcome the one and only Gavin
matz wow to the program yes thank you
for having me Bill you're welcome yes
yes 10 years 10 years 10 years you've
been doing it 10 years yeah yeah yeah
not that long you stupid phone buzzing I
supposed to have it on quiet it's fine
it's fine it's just making a noise all
right before we get started I'm a huge
fan of yours thank you Bill your style
you're completely like you know like I
was saying before there's enough
screaming idiots out there like me yeah
yeah yeah you know I like to think I'm
one of the better screaming idiots that
doesn't know how to write a joke you're
a good screaming idiot I'm a good
screaming idiot but the screaming idiot
now there used to be a lot of screaming
idiots and now now you're the one guy I
like it like it well you know you don't
see a lot of people scream anymore you
got to go with your strengths I knew I
was an idiot I was like What if I turned
it up yeah yeah yeah you're from an
angry angrier F now everybody is more
sad I feel like is that what it is yeah
you know what I mean it's more like it's
not as angry explain explain explain
your generation to an old guy like me
well you know you think about like Hicks
and stuff he's like an angry guy he's
like mad at uh America and now people
are just kind of sad about it there's
not a lot you can do anymore so people
are just sad about I just like how you
reduce Bill Hicks to he's mad at America
but I understand that because it's like
as time goes on
you know PE just everything it's like
people going back like there's so many
people now that just love trashing the
Beatles saying they weren't that good of
a band sure I do think Hicks is good but
I've been I've been watching I've been
on a Hicks kick I I watch him and then I
I feel bad for him just going like you
know like when you watch him like Snap
and everything cuz we've all done that
yeah and you start thinking like you
know there's other options sure but
what's rare with his I feel like cuz he
has like a lot of weird sets that are
just like you know like in Indianapolis
like there's like a 40 minute set
there's like a punchline it's like an
hour and 20 but it's like I'm like how
often were people like recording sets
even you know it's rare to have just
like a club set from someone where it's
like now you kind of got to people show
up with their own camera and tripod it's
embarrassing oh I know it's cuz I I
almost feel like the standup special is
going away cuz it feels like you got to
uh it's all about clips now and and
younger people are just used to like
Instagram you know yeah it's really sad
I mean I had a joke that I lik that
someone commented like oh it took too
long to get to the joke but I'm like the
clip was like 50 seconds I would say
don't listen to that I I know but you
you know what those people are I'm
reading it and then you also like had
reposted so then I know the
notifications are going to you and I
probably you don't look at it but then
I'm also getting it then it's just like
a guy on there calling me gay and then
you're like this guy's calling this guy
I reposted
yeah but I I'm always going to side with
the comic because people do that well I
go to me all the time all the time all
kinds of [__] like uh and it's also all
over the map yeah um well people are
insane and then you know you can just go
to somebody's page and see what they're
going through and this's one guy who's
being kind of mean to me I go to his
page linked to his Facebook because he
got a private page and then I see on
Facebook he was looking for a room to
live in Albany so I was like oh he's
just going through something
he can't find you know what it is is
back in the day yeah back in the day
when there was just like three channels
or even like in if there was just basic
cable like we all were sort of
experiencing the same media reality mhm
but now the rains are completely taken
off it's like yeah so it's like you and
I on our phones are living in two
completely different countries or
realities oh my bubble is insane that I
live in yeah oh okay I'm into bubbles
what's your bubble my bubble is just
kind of just like I don't know bad stuff
happening around the world just feeding
me that oh you get it yeah I get went
that period you got that must be loving
the Gaza Strip huh there's plenty of bad
stuff going on there oh I mean I'm not
but I don't I don't want to see it you
know I want to live outside of that I
want to live I want to live in like like
when Gaza Strip started happening did
you get excited like Netflix dropped a
new series or something oh more tragedy
I would like to live in like a kind of a
you know a propaganda that's good you
know like okay like the like the 50s but
I I'm not I'm not able to so I get I get
everything well 50s was weird where on
TV if you look at it as a white person
uhhuh I mean it was amazing those guys
like Hugh bont on L it to Beaver coming
home in that [__] company car uh it's
got Barbera B billingy right oh yeah the
middle class was strong yeah came with
like an oldmobile you know maybe a Buick
oh he's moving up right then you get up
to like the my granny had a Buick all
right but also what was going on is you
had like the cold war mhm you had uh you
you still have that okay again don't you
think is that still I don't I don't pay
I just I can't like I mean you have kids
you know no you have not that that's not
my excuse okay I just can't handle
watching them separating us and people
allowing it yeah like just watching
everything get politicized from viruses
to electric cars to States
to cities to the kind of shoes you wear
and it's just like just all we're doing
Spotify RS what is that so that's this
is just it's a good marketing tool by
Spotify that at the end of the year you
get your favorite songs you get your
favorite songs your favorite how many
hours you listened and and then people
post it oh yeah but then you're seeing
people you don't like who possibly
listen half scent to the artist oh yeah
the half a sent to the artist they fire
all their workers after uh they've made
you know profit revenue is like yeah so
that's kind of kind of what that is and
then you are like oh well they like this
artist that I like so now I don't know
if I can like them CU this person likes
them so even individuals you know what
generation are you from I'm I'm I'm 1994
so I technically uh Millennial you know
I'm one of those Millennials yeah I know
that we raised yeah and then we blame
you guys for the way we raised them yeah
and then you also say that we suck yeah
I which I didn't do nothing yeah no you
didn't yeah thank you yeah I I don't
have a problem with you you guys yeah
okay okay I'm not I'm trying to bring
the generations together yeah yeah I'm
the guy who's saying when they put these
mandatory kill switches on cars that all
we have to do as a people is just walk
to work for about 6 days and the oil
companies would lose so much [__]
money they' go take those kill switches
out of the car and then like you know
then the politicians wouldn't get the
kickback money and then what they would
have to be is just be like okay you know
the people have spoken but they would
still say you know what's going to
happen would say for now for now that's
like when they they want to have that
RoboCop in San Francisco oh we got one
in New York now yeah people like you're
not [__] doing that and they're like
no we are and they said no you're not
and then they say okay we're not for now
so it's like so we really don't have a
say yeah it's just a grace period of
maybe oh we'll wait a couple months that
was like in New York when they put the
video screens in the back of the Cs you
like get these things the [__] out of
here and people was vandalize them and
[__] and they took them out and then a
few years later they came back and they
were even bigger but I think by then
people were but don't you want to play
games video games and stuff no like in
the car Rod they they have like the
they'll be like they'll have like a a
multiple choice quiz for you while
you're taking the cab 20
blocks Oh no just to distract you yeah
no I'm not into I'm into uh I'm into
just trying to be by myself and be quiet
and just settling it all down cuz I'm a
[__] lunatic so I can't
watch you know I watch those News
Channel
and I start thinking I know what's going
on and I start thinking I have a
solution and then I'm another guy you
know what yeah then you do the solution
you're like we got to put the kill
switches in the car yeah School fans of
my podcast remember those
years it didn't take much to bring up
the Federal Reserve and then I was off
on that thing so what are you going to
blow it up no Jesus Christ you trying to
get me on a watch list no I I I don't
know what I didn't know what I was like
the typical guy going it's is federal
it's fed Express and then like I had I
had no solution yeah of course my
solution is that is I said I have no
solution my here's what it's not me I'm
not involved all right [__] relax the
president okay he just sends like 50
army guys down there and he walks in all
those pencil pushers and he goes yeah
this is over you don't print the money
anymore we don't owe you [__] and that's
a guy who's going to get something done
yeah just the president yeah I know I
know I know but people believe that I
know it used to be so good you used to
you used to think they could do
something yeah they used to promise you
stuff
too a guy making 200 300 Grand a year is
not going to be able to change America
no no no it's too little money it is you
got to have way more money he makes less
money than influencers and I'm supposed
to sit here and believe because color of
his tie and his speeches that he's going
to go in there we got to get Biden some
liquid death oh Biden Jesus we need to
get Biden a home he needs to be in a
[__] home what we really need is we
need two young people running for
presidents that are going to have to
live with their decisions sure I'm
always saying there should be a cap yeah
always there should be says that yeah he
does I mean a lot of people I think
should say there's a cap of like maybe
60 cuz people people work a regular job
they they want to be done at 60 listen
I'm 55 I would put it around 58 58 cuz I
I feel the wheels coming off those last
two years are always the yeah I'm
feeling I'm going a little uh yeah yeah
I mean the White House the problem is
they're going to get those for him he's
so old and if he wins again they're
going to have to get those you know
those seats where they put the chair
they go up the chair real slow like an
escalator I think I think cuz I'm like
he's got to be done on stairs I think he
steps down if he's able to or falls off
a chair oh he steps down from the
presidency falls down from the
presidency and then you got to go with
uh whoever the vice president is what's
her name of there oh Kamala Camala yeah
which I haven't heard a word from her
since she said we did it Joe she's
always out in Santa Monica oh cool I I
don't go out there no or or or Malibu
one of those yeah I fly and there's
always a TFR yeah yeah she's always out
there yeah it's weird it's weird her
quote her quote forever now is they keep
reusing it is the we did it
Joe like that's her quote in the history
books remember when when he got elected
they was like they were filming her to
do a phone call with Joe Biden oh and
she was like we did it Joe and was he
like who are you I'm sure he was like
remind me your name again and how do I
pronounce
that yeah um well we've left your
generation quite a mess yeah I mean I
would say the the younger whatever is is
more a mess I'm like I'm hoping that I
get out of here really it's December 5th
it's 85 degrees out here right now yeah
I mean no even in I know it's LA but
it's not supposed to be like this sure I
mean I've been in New York and I uh you
know the past like five years and it it
it hasn't snowed really the last two
years and I get worried yeah you know I
I try not to
like like this morning I was getting my
kids ready for school yeah and my wife
goes you might want to put our daughter
in shorts cuz it's going to be 85° and
it just like this wave of depression
went over me I was just going what are
we going to do about this she's
like put them in shorts so they're not
hot yeah yeah yeah that gritting the
teeth is is never a good sign yeah no
but I mean I blame God for all of it of
course cuz he's made all of us and he
made all of these [__] idiots and and
he gave people ideas and Loud idiots um
you interestingly enough January 6th
which means a lot to people who pay
attention to the news which you guys had
to remind me uh I'll be going back to
the capital you're going to be at the
union hall in brookin yeah New York and
you got to see you got to see this kid
man I just love I I love your style um
you're a great joke writer thank and
then also the confidence that you have
to have to go at your pace at that
volume
yeah I I mean was that hard for you in
the beginning following loud idiots like
me I mean I mean I mean I came up in
Vancouver and there is like a good club
there that I kind of like whatever this
phrase is my grip my teeth or whatever
cut my teeth I cut my teeth there and it
was pretty nice I mean but doing this
hour on the road I was like I felt like
a comic in like the '90s cuz I did like
from the like
November uh I did Boston and then I sent
that tape to uh Jordy here at ATC and
then they were like okay maybe we can do
something and I was like okay so I
booked all these dates didn't really
hear it from my agent and I booked like
56 cities who shot it too uh my friend
Marcus Russell price oh I know him yeah
yeah he just took pictures uh when I did
a gig in New York yeah yeah he's a great
he's a great he's got a great eye he
does he we really had a i i he executed
that exactly how I wanted cuz I was like
there's no other way it stands out it
stands out it's a really cool looking
special and it should look unique
because of uh your Unique Style so um so
who you handicapping here for the uh for
the next uh there's no is it going to be
these two idiots again yeah it just be
like wrestling it should be like
wrestling and Trump's like [__]
holding Biden down and then [__]
Hillary comes running in from behind the
curtain you know like on Monday Night
Raw I I have no how do we get out of
this Vortex I mean what is the other
option is like
DeSantis uh is he the Florida guy yeah
but think he's kind of like been bombing
recently cuz I haven't heard much from
him and then there's Gavin Nome who I
don't want to win cuz we share the same
first name who's that guy I know he's
the California guy he's the California
guy but you know I'm you know I'm
Canadian so I could just leave yeah you
always have that option what are you
going to do though your country's messed
up too your country is sort of
lowkey messed up like cuz I follow a few
people up there in Canada yeah it's very
much like me it's very quiet and you're
like what is this what is going to
happen I know but there's something
going on where people are saying that
they're giving the country away and blah
they're always giving the country away
they're always trying to separate
Alberta wants to be its own thing Quebec
wants to be its own thing they've
committed horrible atrocities what they
should do is you should let them secede
from the union uhhuh and then attack
them seems like you have a lot of
similar Solutions you occupy yeah yeah
yeah yeah no I I get I get annoyed with
little places acting like they can
defend themselves yeah yeah yeah do you
feel that way about you know that Texas
is always saying
this that they want to do that that they
want to also can I tell you some about
Texas they don't know what they want to
do yeah any more than I do like no one's
thought that through like you know my
favorite thing is you should move to
State they have no state tax it's like
really everybody's just working for free
it's like buying a used car right now
buying a car well you coming with your
piece of [__] we'll go we'll give you
six grand for that car that's worth 500
bucks you're like really and then they
charge you 9 grand for the rust proofing
they're going they're going to get you
in sales tax property tax there's no
[__]
way that you can live in in a in a in a
place with no state tax and they don't
get it somewhere else like how do you
how do you pay for all the
infrastructure I mean yeah I mean I
don't trust Texas I like Texans but I
don't trust Texas oh I don't I don't
trust politicians yeah cuz they're all
grossly underpaid so they can be bribed
by people that way more money anybody
else I mean that guy was down when they
were it was for some reason was C there
I know that guy that guy I don't he went
to Mexico he went to Mexico he said it
was too cold who what the the Ted Cruz
or whatever remember there was like a
there was like really cold yeah yeah
yeah well they say he's the Zodiac
Killer say he's the Zodiac that was like
a that was like a Twitter thing where
people were being like Ted Cruz looks
like the Zodiac drawing isn't that guy
from like 50 years
ago the
Zodiac I thought he was Ted Cruz yeah
yeah who's also he's from Calgary he's
like almost Hitler's age like people
still think that guy's alive it's like
they're yeah yeah people think
everybody's alive yeah they can't accept
Hitler probably died of natural causes
and like a swing set in
Argentina yes yes and everyone's like oh
with Tupac or some corny thing to say no
Tupac like JFK they have the death
photos yeah those are brutal those are
gone they finally caught those guys
too yeah they did it seemed it seemed
pretty basic it's like literally the guy
he fought in the casino uhhuh and it
seems like um why were they working on
this all that time my favorite one was
they thought Suge was involved it's like
okay I'm going to sit on the other side
of him as you shoot at him from this
side like immediately I was like yeah no
yeah didn't Suge also get shot like why
would he be sure he's he was I remember
a video of him doing something crazy in
a car like a couple years ago but drove
over a guy he got freaked out he thought
the guy was going to do something to him
and he drove over him that yeah that's
always happened to me when I'm in a
vehicle and I'm getting freaked out by a
guy well he played the game at a
different level I mean literally your
life was at stake MH you know so I think
he just played the game a little too
long yeah different
time uh you came up in like what the the
90s 70s and ' 80s and then the '90s my
brain was fully formed so I have to take
responsibility for everything from then
on but as far as
like uh what [__] me up was yeah the
70s and ' 80s yeah
yeah yeah and now here we are so you
made it
out I mean it's not like I was in prison
but I mean I definitely I mean it seems
like it was hard for a lot of people to
make it out our next partner is ag1 the
the daily foundational nutrition
supplement that supports the whole body
health so I'm always looking for Life
upgrades which is why I've come to love
and Trust
ag1 why take a bunch of different things
when you can just mix one scoop of
powder and water once a day ag1 was
designed with ease in mind so you can
live healthier and better without having
to complicate your routine ag1 replaces
your multivitamin probiotic and More in
one simple drinkable tablet it's a
foundational Nutri it's a foundational
nutrition supplement that delivers
comprehensive nutrients to support the
whole body Health science-driven
formulation of vitamins probiotics and
Whole Food Source nutrients every scoop
is packed with 75 vitamins and minerals
you get it it's healthy probiotics Whole
Food Source inity high quality gut mood
support boosted energy what more do you
need if you want to take ownership of
your health try ag1 and get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free ag1 travel packs with your first
purchase go to drink
a1.com Bird that's drink alphaf one ag1
/ur check it out well here's the thing
Gen X people I don't know why they keep
this embarrassing that's my generation
right I'm on the I'm on the the metal
heavy metal side of Gen X I I never got
into that grunt [__] okay where like
heavy metal was all about denying what
happened to you as a child and just
partying and like screaming yeah and
just act you could hear yeah just act
like my act right you can't really you
can't really like go inwards when you're
screaming so loud yeah no no it's just
like were you're like a tool guy was I a
tool guy uh I had I've Had My Moments
I'm sort of a closet Gearhead I like
watching people do [__] but I don't have
the balls to take apart my own stuff
right I meant I did mean the band but
yeah yeah yeah you did mean the band
there a band gear no tool oh tool yeah
yeah tool oh yeah tool but Tool's one of
those bands that like I mean they like
like split my brain like when I'm
listening to it cuz I'm trying to figure
out like what's going on the time
signature and all of the Rhythm or
whatever that Danny car's doing
and
um yeah like so I can like I need quiet
music now well it's going to take me my
lifetime to get through their catalog
because each song is so [__] complex
you need like a two we break no I I no I
get lost in it and and and I just I just
the way they they put the whole puzzle
together and then Maynard's voice and
all of that I mean it's they're they're
like a
um you know a Next Level band and then
also what [__] me was I was doing
standup when they came up so I've always
been trying to catch up with them like
I'm always a couple albums behind which
feels like grades yeah you know what I
mean I mean this in a complimentary way
like you don't just put on a tool record
be like oh yeah that's catchy you know
and
then when buying tapes and all of that
[__] went away they weren't on anything
that I was downloading from and I I
didn't want to steal from them so like
then they put out like I don't know like
three or four of them masterpieces so I
have to try to like you know take it
easy go back to it yeah I mean this [__]
to me is is the same way it's like hey
you listen to this Zappa album and the
first time like what the [__] is I don't
know what's going on I've never listened
to Zappa I'm sorry oh my god dude D roza
was always into them and like I was
going dude this is sounds like I I can't
I mean I know they're great musicians I
don't know what's going on here it took
me like 20 years and now I'm listen
going like oh man this is [__]
amazing see I don't mind just like a guy
with a guitar yeah I don't either and
and that's it you know what did get old
at first was was was the guitar player
and just a drummer when the White
Stripes came out I was like oh [__] this
is [__] amazing and then like 50
people did it after that now I've seen
bands in like New York sometimes I go
see like some little shows just some
like newer bands and no drummer just
bass and guitar and they'll have like a
one of those like not like a synth but
some some kind of like keyboard beat
maker type thing I was going to say and
I kind of like that yeah well there you
go there's this band glom I like them
Gom oh all right yeah yeah they only
have like they have like no views but
I'm like I've seen them a couple times
now and they're like amazing oh I never
finished my point which go back on
Generation X is there's all of these
stupid [__] things out there where
they're going like you know you know uh
we grew up in the 70s and ' 80s and they
start showing like [__] we did at the
playground like like we're [__]
veterans or something and then they go
like you know nobody complained when we
were kids cuz no one let's like
everybody did yeah but I also had that I
also had I'm I feel like I'm like the
last generation of kids that had that
like abuse abuse uh you don't think
there's kid Al alcoholic father you know
what I mean like I'm sure there are kids
but I'm saying also Freedom you know
what I mean like could also be like go
outside and don't come home until like
10: and you're and you're like a
9-year-old you know but there there was
abuse and now there's abuse and these
kids don't get to leave home yeah but
they also have a freedom of that they
can go around the world with a [__]
device in their hand I mean it's
unbelievable like if you actually were
smart and use the internet I can't
imagine what you could learn and see as
opposed to me well these the screens are
insane because I've been looking after
um my girlfriend's nephew while I've
been in town he's like almost two and
they don't let him do screen time but if
you give him a screen he's donked out on
Miss Miss Rachel is Miss Rachel yeah I I
finally have now she's ruining the kids
well I've realized yeah I feel like
using your phone in front of your kids
is like smoking in front of them yeah
cuz then they want it and uh they
literally like zone out and it's a
really easy way to control your kids
yeah yeah nees nees Patel has a great
joke about that where he's like in 50
Years it'll be like smoking and people
will be putting the phone to their neck
like I used
Instagram
I didn't use
earbuds um so January 6 Union Hall what
is Union Hall it's like a little uh
performance base they always have like
standup B um it's like the Bell House in
Brooklyn I guess those you'd consider
those like little alt rooms right it's
like a I do like a monthly there just to
run material outside of the clubs oh
that's cool so where are you based out
of I'm in Brooklyn oh you are yeah yeah
blows my mind how much Brooklyn has
changed yeah I mean I wasn't there
before butly when moved to New York in
the '90s was [__] terrifying I the
the the the Fashion District whatever
the [__] you call I don't know that even
exists in Manhattan yeah after 5:00 and
the sun went down that was in Manhattan
yeah I was on like 20s something Street
I remember they reopened catcher rising
star and I'd have money for a cab and I
would take the [__] six train down or
something I would walk ACR Town it was
uh it was way on the west side so I
would always be like running to try not
to be late and I you we walking on the
street you felt like you were an escape
from New York because there was all of
this trash on on the street from like
you know the day's work of course and
then everything was like you know the
metal things were all pulled down and it
was just really dirty and [__] dingy
and it was like during the day it was
this crazy like level of activity like
um and then once that started getting
more developing like residential and
businesses and restaurants the other one
was down near uh the World Trade Center
in Tribeca and all that like that place
after after hours during a weekday was a
terrifying place to go I
actually was down there
uh it was like I was coming back and I
got off in the wrong stop on September
it would be 9th so it was sept by the
time I got down there it was the early
hours of September 10th 2001 uhhuh and I
got off at the World Trade cuz I [__]
up I remember I was coming up from
Philly and there's the Penn Station in
New Jersey and I was was going to Penn
Station in New York and I [__] up and
I got off the wrong one and I got on the
next PATH train it took me to the World
Trade and I was so [__] pissed cuz I
was like there's going to be nobody down
there I'm not going to be able to get a
cab and I [__] came out of the World
Trade and I saw this cab yo yo yo and he
saw me I totally looked out and sprinted
never even looked up at him you know he
took it for granted had no [__] idea
oh my gosh yeah wow yeah well imagine if
comedy clubs went till Monday night
story have you have you ever told that
before yeah I but it's not insane cuz it
was just it was sort of like I mean
right right before it was literally
about yeah about I don't know oh my gosh
yeah just the wrong stop yeah got off
the wrong stop but I mean it was there
no D there was no danger there it was
just like what was going to happen where
I was and my whole mindset when I got
out was just like oh get a cab and get
out of here I'm like you [__] idiot
get down here and the trains like you
know the trains at that time used to run
every half right missing a stop missing
a stop is one of the wor sometimes I
just forget to get off and then I'm like
ah [__] I got to go back to Union hey I
I did I do have a bone to pick with you
though go ahead you're you're bit about
F-150s and pulling like the mirrors in
and stuff I have an F250 so like does
that also apply cuz I have to pull my
mirrors in no hits yeah yeah yeah I look
that made so many people mad and they're
like oh you don't work with your hands
I'm like uh
okay hilarious tell like 40% of the time
when I pull my miror and I think about
your joke I mean just Rel I mean it is
really just about my dad and he has a
GMC so you know that's just where that
came from and what is the joke instead
of pulling it in why don't why don't you
take a good long hard look in it you
know and
reflect I mean that's a fun one to do I
mean that's that was always fun to do in
like to I mean in whatever where people
have those and they need them would they
yeah and most people are good sport
Sports though right yeah of course you
know some people get mad and then it'll
be the the the wives or whoever is at
the random show seeing me unfortunately
you know that just showed up at the
comedy club they like it more and then
you know you get the look over and then
the guy gets mad you know I'm really
just thinking about Go Bananas in
Cincinnati oh yeah that was a rough week
is that green couch still in the [__]
Green Room I think maybe I was there the
week before they went to the Super Bowl
dude that thing and that was a night
that was a nightmare bill that was a
nightmare cuz it was a fun Club yeah it
was it was it would have been fun and
they were the shows were all packed you
know it's not really in Cincinnati it's
a little out but I mean you know
everybody was the happiest they'd ever
been cuz the Bengals were about to go to
the Super Bowl so they were so they were
wasted and I'm trying to run this hour
oh and you're going all
monotone all H day H day literally I
have a clip of people just yelling H day
I was wearing like some like Nikes that
had like an orange accent and someone
was just like immediately there were
like Bengals colors and I was like I
could I could not you watch football at
all I watch some you know I used CFL guy
yeah I'm a big CFL fan NHL what do you
watch you don't watch any sports no I
watch NHL NBA I used to be big into to
NFL but I kind of gave it up but I'm a
big you know NHL I watch the Bruins
games you do I'm kind of like I I just
don't have [__] time anymore like I'm
becoming that guy I can't talk that's
fine I can't name the names anymore I
don't even know honestly just like I
don't even like talking about it Sports
I would rather just watch it and get a
little
Escape it's my thing yeah so what do you
do what how do you waste your time on
this planet how do I waste my time yeah
I don't know I walk my dog it's not a
waste of time that's a good thing it's
you could call it wasting time I go to
Prospect Park you know I go to the
library I hang out with friends we play
basketball you know I play You're have a
very healthy life yeah have a go to the
library this is
amazing I mean I mean yeah I I uh I mean
I I I got sober like three years ago and
so I just you don't know I don't know
all right cook food what what was your
uh drug of choice I mean I was I mean I
you don't have to say it I mean yeah you
know I was into drinking and then I
would do like some pills and stuff like
that and just like what everybody's
doing people are doing pills huh yeah oh
is that sound like a dad are you doing
pills are you doing the pills yeah I
mean shits that's how all those [__]
starlets used to die back in the day
yeah they take downers and then
everybody was always having a couple of
martinis to unwind and then you didn't
wake up well I broke my collar bone in
in high school list I don't want to hear
your
excuses no I broke my collarbone in high
school and then they gave me like some
like you know some stuff and then that's
kind of how whatever happened not a
dependency but then I was like you know
it was like the Pand that happens that
happens I I I have a dear friend of mine
had that happen yeah um
yeah they they put you they give you
this really intensive stuff that that's
the kind of thing that [__] bugs me
though is that they can do that [__] and
they can turn you into a [__] addict
off of a collar bone yeah and nobody
gets like in trouble for that [__] no
and then they spend their time
nitpicking and buying art what's buying
well you know the Sackler family who
like created all that they had like they
have like wings in every Art Museum oh
they do yeah which they're like taking
they got people they got people hooked
on synthetic heroin and then turn around
they bought like yeah something like the
family the Sackler family they're the
same ones they created vum uh when that
was big and then they're also like uh
what was it what what is the new Big
opiate that everyone was taking get a
big Standing Ovation from the volume
crowd though I mean that didn't kill
people the way like the opioids did
right I mean I guess you don't really
know because I feel like it probably
killed a lot of people's decision making
cuz it was basically they're just giving
it and marketing it to like you know
wives stay-at home moms oh yeah which
like seems like a hell now they just
Market exercise equipment to them yes
that's that's healthy too no it isn't
those spin
classes yeah how many people bought that
stupid pelaton bike and I was just
sitting there oh so many so many people
have that hanging on the well you know
sometimes I do like moving jobs in uh
New York and that's always a big one
moving people's
pelons that's a [__] right yeah I
imagine the basic is probably it's it's
and it's awkward weight well it's only
it's whoever whoever grabs the
front that that's the worst part yeah
yeah yeah cuz that's where the wheel is
which is heavy and you know they got to
take the screen off and it's it's a
whole thing so you you want you help
people move too some sometimes yeah
sometimes you just got all kinds of time
with this sobriety huh well no I mean
that I have to do because you know I'm
that's a little under the table I
honestly shouldn't even be talking about
as a Canadian you know what I mean I'm
down here stealing the under table jobs
but no a lot of comedians work for this
moving company that see that's my thing
like you just said that as a little joke
you make [__] 50 bucks every once in
a while to help somebody move I feel
like news channels and stuff would focus
more on that than they would on somebody
coming up with synthetic heroin and
causing all of this you know death and
misery and all of that that's why I kind
of
stopped uh watching all of that [__] cuz
I was just like this is just clear this
is all oh yeah it's like anti look at
this look at this yeah yeah so and
that's why when people are like this
guy's never worked with his hands I'm
like okay well I've done a four floor
walk up in August in the summer with
like 80 boxes in a pelaton yeah yeah I
want to reply I want to be like well you
don't actually know but you know I don't
want to blow up my spot like I just did
on this podcast I know you know the
amount of people that drive trucks that
don't work with their hands you're
looking at one well that's that's what
I'm talking [__] Texas dude you're in
when you're in Dallas and in Houston I
mean every pickup trucks looks like it
just came off the showroom well and
that's my problem too with like I mean
gas prices are so high and that's a part
of that joke is is they're always mad
you always mad about the gas I don't
give a [__] about gas well I mean yeah
you're doing good no I never I just but
some people do care some people it's
like a major talking they do care they
do care it's like one of the only that's
when they're patriotic yes they're
patriotic when if we go you know bomb
that's why that's why they want to go
bomb some people yeah go bomb some
people so the gas the industrial
military complex whatever you want to
call it think we're figuring it all out
I mean I think I could on if I had
what's going on in Canada cuz I don't
buy Michael Moore's version of your of
Canada what was his version well that he
did this [__] documentary and he's
like yeah up there you don't have to
lock your doors and everybody's all
[__] hoopy doopy me you definitely
you definitely have to lock your door I
would lock your door I would lock my
door anywhere I had a friend who never
locked his door say that you couldn't
and then he comes down here and then he
shows somebody buying a [__] rifle in
a bank and he's sitting there looking
down he you know it's creative editing
to make everybody look [__] stupid
and then everybody up there in Canada be
look sure and everybody up in Canada
likes to be like yeah we don't have guns
I mean that is kind of like the main
issue is everybody here has a gun and we
don't have we don't really have like you
can't get a
handgun oh you can't get a handgun up
there I mean yeah I mean I had a friend
he's had hunting rifles is that why you
guys fight on the ice that's why we
fight that's why we're such
goons that's why we're such goons is
because we can't just shoot someone I'd
be all for getting rid of guns if you
could actually do it yeah I mean you
can't you can't it's over it's it's out
there you can't it's done have you ever
shot one yes and you liked it uh I mean
it's fun it's [__] fun shooting you
feel like a badass I like I love the way
they look I mean you once think about
guns I'd ra I'd owed them to look at
them uhhuh just cuz I like the way they
look especially if like just to have the
dirty hairy gun I think I mean it's it's
[__] up to say but it's gorgeous no I
do like like a old uh a revolver I like
a revolver I just think it's [__] bad
like this and I also I think that you
should only get six attempts to shoot
someone yeah you know I only bullets
only Six Bullets yeah I feel like those
semi-automatic and fully automatic those
are for [__] like it's just like
those are like everybody gets a trophy
like everybody gets a kill like if you
can't squeeze off six and hit whatever
you're mad at then I mean you lose it's
like a carnival game carnival game you
get three Tri you're getting twice as
many tries with a [__] revolver you
got to have you ever seen those big
banana those extended [__] magazines
uhhuh yeah no psych why don't you learn
how to shoot better it also doesn't look
good aesthetically compared to the
revolver it's like a crooked dick yeah
hanging off you know what's an elephant
dick you ever see the elephants just
walking by you ever see those videos
they big swinging [__] you know Bill
I I don't I don't tend to that kind of
stuff up well you look at animalic I see
animal videos it's not animal porn it's
not you animal on her back I wasn't
saying you were watching that hey you
know you see things you see things on
the interet see you see things that you
can't so talk to me about your bubble
again I saw donkey kill a [__] hyena
the other day on the internet blew my
mind I would love to see that I didn't
even know they in the same little
situation they uh I guess they're very
protective of of the farm animals and
they're very protective of the order and
he grabbed this [__] by the back of
the Scruff of his neck like a dad
beating the [__] out of some punk
grabbed him by the Scruff and just kept
slamming the thing on the ground and the
thing was showing his teeth but it it it
it doesn't have the ability to do D the
three St just poke the
eyeballs and uh he [__] killed the
thing yeah yeah yeah that's the kind of
stuff on the internet yeah well that's
what I I I was trying to what was I
trying to find the other day it was
something a a bear versus something else
cuz it sort of fascinated me I saw a
grizzly bear kill the black bear mhm
they they're not supposed to run into
each other and he got super Territorial
and I love bears I [__] hate Bears
why do you hate a bear because like a
California bear that gets in the trash
it's just like a big raccoon no my thing
about bears is the way that they kill
you like if I was going to get killed if
I had to choose between a mountain lion
in a Bear Mountain Lion all day okay
I'll get m a little bit and then it's
going right to the neck it's me I'm done
done but a bear is playing with you a
little bit well it's eating through your
back to break your [__] spine
whatever the [__] it's doing it's just
it starts to it's like you're like sushi
you have a lot of intrusive thoughts
about being killed by animals uh yeah
you want to hear my my my top three yes
top three in no particular order I love
that you got favorite oh oh yeah no
particular order sharks I mean terrible
terrible bear bear kodo
Dragon okay and what's what's the the
the through line of all of them is
they're eating you while you're still
alive and then when you're drown for the
flare yes you throw drowning in there
yeah I yeah the Sharks terrify me and
that's probably why I don't go in like
the ocean I don't at all even a lake I
don't go in the ocean I don't go in the
forest yeah I would never go in the
forest no not on the forest you like you
don't like a nice
hike clear your mind no I like a hike on
a big [__] Hill and all the way
around it it's surrounded by
civilization so then I know you know you
like a walk listen I can deal with the
coyote but even then you know there
always I got a little sister she goes
into the mountains for like 3 days what
camps okay and she's Canadian without a
gun Canadian without a gun she might
have like a flare or a be bear spray or
something yeah yeah yeah it's it's
psychotic and she's
21 and she's T she's
tiny she loves to do it she's a a human
slider yeah yes I mean I would never I
mean I like bears but from a distance
listen I love all of those animals I'm
not in a reptiles it's just like mammals
they they have a Vibe I don't like a
snake they seem alive this same sister
she was dating a guy thank God they
broke up I could not stand them um but
he had a snake as a pet and that to me
is whatever we talk about like whatever
red flag is I'm like it's liter it's the
representation of Satan that's and he
has it as a pet and I'm like he doesn't
represented the weakness of women
something about women isn't that how the
gay people that started the Catholic
Church the gay people in hiding yes yes
yes the closet of gays said something in
that it's about women and they had to
pick something that sort of was shaped
like a dick so they could stay
interested to write the story they had
to stay interested these are all facts
here
people these are all all facts well um I
need I need a a spot like Union Hall
where I can just [__] can do a once a
week yeah I'm getting I'm going to do
another special next year and then uh
what number is that I don't know I like
that you don't know I don't know it's
just more like uh I've done what I can
with this thing yeah these ideas are
good they're ready to go yeah and I saw
you after I think you taped
um in that spot in Denver that big
outdoor what is that red rocks Red Rocks
which I went to when I was just at the
Comedy Works to visit I'm like that
place is crazy I was like such a fun I
was like how do you do standup
there uh well it helps if you're a draw
like I wouldn't want to just go there in
front no but I'm saying if 10,000 people
don't know you like I wouldn't want to
open cuz I did that yeah I did stand up
there in front of an animated special
they were showing um cartoons or
whatever yeah and I was working the
Comedy Works they said hey they want
some comedians to go up there and
perform I was like oh [__] Red Rocks you
kidding me that's cool I would love to
and I went up there and it was not it
was not uh it wasn't like they were
hostile it's just like they they didn't
give a [__] they weren't listening yeah
but I did notice in that special too you
kind of Rift off the top to kind of get
yourself in and and then it's feel it
felt like you were riffing to kind of
settle down or like get it's just so
crazy to walk out and do that no that's
just what I do to avoid my act cuz that
was that special was like not I was just
docu menting being there and then it
came out good so I all right let's put
this out um but like I was just being
like well when am I ever going to get to
be here again this would be really cool
yeah let me film this it's like Fenway
it's like I'm not going to put that out
as a special but like I I do want to be
able to someday watch it and be like wow
man I can't believe that happened yeah
are those venues you had in your mind
like before you've done them where
you're like hell no yeah it seems Seems
delusion it seems delusional yes when I
started out like the big thing was if
you could come the big Club was um The
Comedy Connection in fuel Hall uhuh and
I remember seeing like this just so
crazy Damon Wayan all right from uh when
when Living Color was at its height I
remember he came down there and sold out
six shows and nothing flat and it was
like a 400 seater it was 2400 seats and
it was just like there just wasn't
Comics doing that it was just I I can't
explain it it was um like bands were
huge but comedians there was sort of
this ceiling every once in a while like
I I want to say that like
um with the craziness of the internet
now like if you weren't In Living Color
then you would have done an arena right
but back then the way the whole thing
worked out is you went clean in a comic
club which was still a shitload of money
which was amazing um and there was only
a couple guys it was like that were just
doing theaters it was like Bill Cosby
George
Carlin and I don't know who else there
was only a couple of guys that were
actually playing like theaters but like
if you were one of the biggest people
out there you you were selling out
comedy clubs so the dream wasn't any
bigger than that right like I never
thought cuz you know dice had done MSG
MSG but he was like dice like I it was
just like you know and Steve Martin had
done like Nassau Coliseum I have that
record that dice did like uh I think
it's the day the laughter died where he
went down to Danger Fields after
MSG and uh was it after I wasn't I I
mean the lore to me is that he did MSG
and then he went down and he like
whatever bombed you know what I mean and
put that record out which I don't think
it's a I don't think he's bombing but I
do like when the people walk out and and
the guy yells you're about as funny as a
bag of
milk you can like hear it like crystal
clear on the vinyl it's um yeah know
that's an amazing amazing [__] album
um yeah so the yeah the the dream was
like the dream was I'll get to the point
where you know you're selling out uh
comedy clubs and then show business
would come around and they would try to
build an act around your act sure do a
sitcom you know and I was a young
ideological IDE whatever [__] angry
guy yeah I was just like [__] sitcoms
they're not funny so yeah I'm the same I
could be the same way I'm like SNL's for
[__]
nobody's was you know I I guess only
thing I wanted is just to like sell out
clubs I wanted to do I I what I wanted
to do was be a comic that could sell out
the comedy connection and then I wanted
to be in like badass [__] movies like
you know [__] Rambo movies and [__]
like that like like a drama or like
State of Grace and stuff like that yeah
like I really uh you know movies were
like a huge thing yeah when I was
growing up of course I feel like they're
slowly coming
back uh I hope so cuz that's what I'm
doing right now yeah yeah you're doing
movies now well I mean I finally made
one here at ATC and then you know it did
really well so looks like we're going to
get an opportunity to make another one
so I just look at it
like if it's going away I don't give a
[__] M you know yeah you got to do
because I'm still going to do it cuz I
like doing it I really like movies and
then I look at like you know Quinton
Tarantino who's like buying movie
theaters out here and he's just going to
show movies and stuff like I I like he's
saying this is his last movie and I'm
like if this is really his last movie
and he just made 10 epic movies and then
he retires and he runs a couple of movie
theaters I mean I don't know the guy at
all but I would have to say if you told
like little Quinton Tarantino whatever
how many years ago that that was going
to be his life he'd be like that is
[__] perfect yeah I mean I people I I
have friends that we talk about like
what are we going to do cuz you know you
kind of don't want to do stand up
forever no it it's mostly ends bad if
you do that you know like there there's
some people where it's like oh cool yeah
you can keep going and you can be
current and like there's like great
examples like a peperone or something
but like for the most part it it it's
it's on a smaller scale it's like you
know kind of embarrassing to going no if
if you no being out there cuz you have
to be yes yeah I don't want to be that
guy but like that that's a good point
but then I've also been like so what are
you going to do after I'm like I don't
know maybe like a I would like like a
candy
shop that's funny me and FY talk about
having a a cigar bar like a cigar bar
yeah yeah I guess that's the adult
version of
that what
is um you ever go to Ray's candy shop
I've been there get an egg cream I did
from old man first time ever was [__]
delicious he was working too no he
wasn't it was uh uh his
oh yeah or whatever yeah I like I like
that that that's happening there's this
butcher shop Albanese meets and um it's
like the only kind of Italian butcher
left um and now the granddaughter is
running it oh thank God no see that
that's a big thing I I go to that I'm
like what am I leaving behind if I have
a child are they going to have to do
stand up I'm like
no I know I thought about that the other
day and what was your conclusion as far
as like what I'm leaving behind yeah
I would just have it more be in the
realm of like you know he didn't you
know he hurt some people but not too
many overall he was you know he had his
moments where he was kind of a decent
guy I don't
um I don't really think about that type
of [__] I S I got depressed about how
old I was mhm uh a couple nights ago and
but then I also don't have like a fear
of like uh like I'm going to die and be
judged in this person's is going to be
mad at me it's just so clearly invented
by human beings mhm that that's what the
[__] happened yeah I also don't think
you're
old uh I think you would say
Prime and I'm not just being
complimentary but I mean that's just
more of a hopeful thing for me I'm
almost 30 so I'm like I'm like what what
is this going to end up like being 40 to
55 was the fastest 15 years of my life
and the next 15 I'm 70 so yeah I mean it
it it like it it does go by
fast but I always just turn around I
just always think like well there's
nothing I can do about it
um but I I and I always try to get out
of that mindset because you know what I
found with older people what we do is
when we turn 30 we're wishing we were in
our 20s in our 30s and then you get in
your 40s and you were wishing you're in
your your 30s when you're in your 40s
and then your 50s you wish you were in
your 40s or 30s whatever and you don't
enjoy like this because you're sort of
buying into uh
you know kind of like what you see on TV
or on your phone or whatever that like
it's all about being young yeah yeah
well I also I also that's why people are
obsessed with like
Nostalgia which I always find like so
gross you know like for like a broad
example of like a like a Disney people
but they're like 40 [__] weird yeah
it's really weird yeah those adults
people of uh verie and Bobby Kelly were
talking about that the adults yeah that
have like a season ticket to disy and
they buy like the ears well it's only
because Vegas like sucks now I think oh
you're blaming Vegas I didn't see that
com yeah I'm blaming Vegas you know I
like that yeah yeah [__] Vegas Vegas
isn't like cool anymore you know so now
people want to go on a [__] ride a
little coaster you know but if Vegas was
still cool it deal it's like if it's if
it's not going to be cool it's really
not going to be cool it's so not cool I
mean I mean Vegas makes me sick that's
why I was thinking you know people
always like talking about the job crisis
in America but I'm like I've been to
Vegas and I'm like people go there with
their families and I'm like how the [__]
do they afford this what job crisis what
job crisis cuz these people have money
yeah so either they're lying to you or
everybody just maxing out a credit card
yes yes I actually did meet someone and
they used to their dad used to take them
to Vegas as a kid but he he would he
would try to make or break the uh money
for the vacation there which is just a
whole other traumatic
situation oh boy boy it's a sucker born
every moment you know what's funny how
much [__] has changed like I feel like
when when you stop being able to buy
like as a souvenir an ashtray of the
casino you stayed at okay I've never
even heard of this for me you know the
the souvenir is when uh that stopped
that I used to feel like I would get all
the time cuz go on like road trips as a
kid um is the penny remember you'd put
the penny in the thing y you twist it
but it would cost you a dollar to press
it yeah that's done and then people like
that's actually a felony cuz you
desecrated money yeah and you're like
well this machine does that and there's
no cops here
so well I feel like you and I could
drive across the country and we would
never run out of [__] to talk about like
you know what else is [__] up and then
you would make some weird like I never
would have connected Vegas with Disney I
was saying that that that has to do with
like but they're the similar they're
similar like things you know no entities
they are they aren't yes they suck
people in and they ruin them all right
well then so's religion religion sure I
agree on a larger scale you're paying
with a broad brush here yeah but that's
all brushes are broad no they're not
they got those little ones with pores
and drugs I'm a paint by I'm a paint by
numbers guy Bill gambling and then you
get over here like I would know like
those people that have the season
tickets you wonder do they have such a
great childhood or was it such a bad is
it they doing the Michael Jackson thing
where they had no childhood so now they
want to right around a choo choo tra yes
yes yes well you know what with uh with
Michael I think it was like about a
whole other
thing I mean but I how the [__] you get
quitted that's my thing though like it's
just like but he got quitted it doesn't
make any any I guess if you're rich you
just get off I don't know I have no
[__] idea all I know is one time I
flew over never Neverland yeah you flew
over it yeah just to see what was up
they said it would never land ranches
out there listen it was I was with uh
flying with somebody else and the guy
goes yeah you're up in Santa EZ and he
goes look at that mountain you see that
triangle he goes it's to the left of
that is that still up there yeah that
ranch is still there yeah some of the
rides were taken down some of the rides
I can tell you this was it a mechanical
failure from the air it uh doesn't look
good cuz we flew over like oh my god
there it is and you're thinking like
Michael Jackson and and then you you
look at it you think about what you got
acces of you're like oh God [__] uh
yeah yeah there's some rust on those
rides uh yeah I'm not going to go down
that road that's no no no that's yeah
it's not fun it's a dark thing well I
really appreciate uh you coming on my
podcast I think you're an amazing talent
thank you Bill uh you're January 6th
we're going to take that day back man I
say that uh you we're going to normalize
we're going to normalize January 6 I
hate all of that speak I'm an empath uh
January 6th at Union Hall in Brooklyn go
check this guy out while you can still
see him in a small place like that I
think you're an amazing amazing comedian
and a fascinating person to talk to
thank you so much for cominging on on
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast have a great
weekend you [__] and I'll see you on
Monday hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Monday
Morning podcast for Monday December 7th
oh
the weather outside is
frightful but yahua so
delightful so if you don't [__] mind
spread your legs spread sorry hey it's
December everybody a December to
remember um happy holidays oh it's the
holiday
season so Merry Christmas I don't give a
[__] if you find that offensive cuzin
you're kind of [__] on my religion
um is Merry Christmas still offensive to
people I can't wait for somebody to wish
me a happy hukkah and I'm going to blow
a gasket how dare
you
um how dare you say something nice from
your religion how [__] dare you um I
kind of [__] up this year with my
Christmas shopping where you know who's
kidding who when you're married it's all
about getting your [__] wife
something that's going to keep her
[__] Yap shut for maybe 2 3 days
who's kidding who you know what I mean
are they ever really happy with
you I'm
asking you know something let's try to
spin this in a positive way if you have
a
wife okay if you're a gay dude and and
you know you feel like you're more the
dude right and you're you're [__]
your your your husband is always
pitching a fit of just every you know
what I mean and you're just sitting
there going what the [__] is with this
dude why can't he just [__] can can
you just can you get a run together of 4
days of just being generally happy with
me okay if anybody is in that situation
and you have figured out a
way to somehow get that to get that
person to the fifth day could you please
email me and tell me what your strategy
is I don't give a [__] male female it's
not like there's some [__] guys out
there you know I'm sure women deal with
that some Moody [__] I should
talk I'm pretty [__] Moody but
generally speaking I like to think I'm
in a good mood but I'm just saying you
know what I mean so anyway so I go out
um you know and I got my wife the gift
and on you know the gift you know thing
everything else is just to fill up the
space underneath the tree you know you
get her some [__] sweatpants you know
no at all I just you know I figured you
could wear them hanging around the house
I'm not I'm not saying you got to go to
the gym you know you get her uh you get
her some mittens you know some be jerky
is sticking in the stocking you're just
trying to flush it out at that point
you've already dropped a ton of cash
right and God knows what the [__] is she
going to what's she going to get for you
huh one of those pumps to [__] pump
up that Sports Illustrated football you
got like [__] 15 years ago when your
team won a
championship wh what what the [__] I
can't even like I'm trying to think the
last time I heard a guy friend of mine
get excited about whatever the [__] he
got for Christmas you know what I mean
what what what the BRS do okay they
expecting something big from their
husband and then they go out and they
blow the cash on all the kids they don't
give a [__] about you you know what I
mean you're like that [__] third
shift night you know security guard of
the house that that's basically what it
is you know I mean if she could if she
could build a little [__] ouse you
know right next to the front door and
you could just sit in there all night
with a clipboard checking people in and
out and say walk in and out of the house
you know wearing a little
uniform uh good afternoon Mrs how are
you I'm really being over dramatic right
now my my situation isn't that bad but
you know what but you exaggerate for
comedic
effect so anyway so I got the I got the
big gift out of the way I got the big
one you know the one that you know won't
make her sulk until Valentine's Day
generally speaking all right I don't
give a [__] how cool your wife is okay
they just they slide into sulking you
know just the way like those mid 880s
Jaguars always had [__] electrical
problems it's the same [__] thing
they they can't help it it's it's a
design
flaw um jeez I'm going hard this week
um what am I trying to say here so I
went and I got the big thing and I kind
of just I don't know I just felt like
because I got the big one out of the way
so early I had all of this [__] time
now all of a sudden it's December
7th there's only [__] whatever 17
more shopping days before it's you know
um unless you got to shop Christmas
morning then I guess you got 18 but at
that point what are you doing picking
lemons off your [__] neighbor's
tree
um so I got to get some [__] done but I
have to Hype my uh my cartoon that's
coming out F is for family this is the
big push in fact this morning it starts
I'm going to uh go do some radio
here and um I'm going to New York City
next week and then I come back out here
to LA and I do a whirlwind tour of um
you know doing some press so I'll
definitely be going into OPI and Jimmy
before everybody asked they
always why wouldn't I when have I
not um Bill maybe they're asking because
they want to hear you on the show all
right you
know fair enough fair enough so um today
I'm doing the podcast then I'm doing
um I'm doing uh the
press and uh then I have to do a little
bit of Christmas shopping I got to
[__] knock it out over the next 3
days I got to get the you know I got to
flesh out the cast here right it's like
I got a shitty [__] sitcom script you
know and I already signed on the movie
star that isn't selling tickets in the
movie theater anymore so I got my
[__] lightning rod of Fame and now I
just got to flesh it out with [__]
that's going to prop it up that's going
to compliment it
you know what I mean so that's what uh
that's what my goal is and
um you know I'll tell you another year
without kids it's starting to [__] with
me but I got to be honest with you after
watching that whole [__] not even
watching I got in the car my wife
listens to and [__]
[Music]
P Morning Becomes
Eclectic that was the electric eel band
doing their version of
acdc's Back in Black on a
viola if you'd like to download that
that's available at gof [__]
yourself.com
um so I had she had on NPR and I got in
the car and I was driving down the
street and I was I guess there was some
big global warming Summit and at this
point not even the corporate [__] can
deny that we're having an
effect and now that they finally came
around and
said yeah we are affecting it they then
quickly said but at this point point
it's too late
so basically we might as well continue
on what we're doing and it's just like
what I mean that's the same thing like I
remember when Pete Rose finally admitted
that he was gambling on
baseball after 20 [__] years no I
never I never gambled on baseball I
never gambled on baseball I never
gambled on baseball 5 years later I
never gambled on baseball 10 years never
G no not nowhere he just goes yeah I
gambled on baseball okay there now now
let me in the hall
it's like wait a minute wait wait wait a
second you know he was already rounded
second thinking he was going to the hall
helmet flew off right going to slide in
head first to
third um same [__] thing so that just
made so it's just going to get worse and
they just sort of
nonchalantly talked
about the hellacious world in the future
that our children and our children's
children are going to have to live in
and now it just kind of made me feel
like you know maybe it should end with
me
so that's uplifting
oh jingle bells jingle bells jingle all
the way um we don't like that song we
feel that there's sexual undertones
jingle all the way as in going all the
way and you know the snow is white you
know technically speaking so is your
jizz if you would have drao it's more of
a uh whoo your cream pie sort
of color oh my God what am I doing I'm
talking about not having children I'm
comparing snow to jizz this is just what
is this you know what this is it's
[__] entertaining to listen to
Somebody slowly going off the rails
during the holidays I got to tell you
it's got to be a fun thing um oh I did a
uh I did a podcast the uh I'd hit that
podcast which is actually actually a
drummer podcast and uh if you saw some
of the guests that they've had on there
um professional [__] drummers you
know of the highest order you'd be like
well what the [__] did they have this
clown coming on there for I'd say you
know everyone that's one of the great
things about being a comedian you know
what I mean every once in a while they
just bring you on some [__] that you
have no business being on Stick you on a
Food Channel or some [__] like that but
it's uh it's called I'd I'd hit that uh
podcast I want to thank Dave for having
me on there we talked about
um talked about everything man um a
little bit about drums but
uh I just got done uh doing a flight
flying the uh helicopter obviously uh
and I've been soloing everybody I find
the thing about once you get your
license you know what I mean and then
you can legally solo there is that pit
in your stomach of like dude you're
really going to let me go up there by
myself you know there's this whole weird
thing when you're learning to get your
pilot's license is like you get to a
certain point where you start getting a
little cocky and you're thinking like
when is this guy going to solo me dude
I'm [__] ready when the [__] is this
going to happen I can do this
look at him his his feet everything is
off the controls I'm flying this [__]
thing I'm bringing it in right on the
numbers I'm doing this [__] when the
[__] is this guy going to solo me and
then one day they go all right you're
ready and then you're like really you
really think so your balls shrink right
up into your [__]
gut so um you know I got my license in
the end of end of May and uh I had not
done a solo
flight since um I was still a student
just
being you know combination of busy with
uh travel on the road and editing the fs
for family and then also I didn't want
to solo until I took the advanced auto
rotation class which is what I did in
August and September then I had my big
run coming up to the New York City gig
so now I finally had the time and uh I
did three flights last week I did one
with an instructor and then the flight I
did with the instructor I did it twice
um solo and uh I got tell it was [__]
awesome
I flew up the uh 710 and actually this
time I added Dodger Stadium and did uh I
fly on the right hand side right so I
just did a right orbit over Dodger
Stadium and then flew over to uh the
Rose Bowl did a right orbit saw him
working on the
field um crossed El Monte at Midfield
and then went back to Long Beach and
um I did [__] up one time with the radio
calls cuz that's the big thing it's the
Radio
Calls I uh thought I was talking to Long
Beach Tower but I was actually still
talking to the LA Basin which is just
basically this big giant area where
everybody's flying around I swear to god
dude you get better at listening but you
can't hear what some people are saying
like those [__] people have been
flying forever
you 1.5 you're like what what the [__]
did you just say these [__] people
who fly around mumbling into the goddamn
[__] radio it's just like
I I don't for the life I speak i anun l
you know I [__]
enunciate you know I Basin traffic this
is
helicopter one Sierra
Hotel flying Northbound I I [__]
annunciate everything I go slow these
fun guys B
traffic I you know what I listen to at
that point I just listen for the number
I hear him go 1.5 I'm like all right I'm
at 1,000 ft he's at, 1500 even if that
[__] ass flying right at me he's
going to be 500 ft above me but if I
just 1,000 all right you're at the same
level as me I have no [__] idea where
you're at so then I either go up or down
[Music]
ft so anyways doing something like that
really just as far as flying
um just sent my confidence through the
roof and like it's just like starting
the thing up and shutting it down too
the whole [__] thing just doing the
whole thing um
and uh you would think that that would
make my confidence just in general go
through the
roof you know flying a helicopter
solo you know over the city of La with
all that [__] traffic that's up there
I was able to do that twice last week
for about collectively 2 hours by
myself yet I'm going to make lasagna
today and I'm nervous to make the
noodles some scratch does that make any
[__]
sense you know I'm not I can't possibly
die doing that it just it just doesn't
make any [__] sense
right I don't know I'm talking about all
I know is FIS for family is coming uh
December 18th the same day is like the
15th installment of Star Wars okay so
you got a choice to make all right and
I'm obviously going to
lobby for the fs for family side okay
now picture
this all right right you can
either stand in [__] like a fourmile
line next to some jerk off dress like
Boba Fett or [__] chewbaca and people
acting out lightsaber fights and all of
that [__] thing shivering as homeless
people come up to you hitting you up for
money and then [__] you know e
entertainments down there hi I'm Billy
Bush down down here with a bunch of jerk
offs who don't realize in three days
they could walk in like a [__]
gentleman and just sit down and watch
this movie it's not going
anywhere you could get involved in that
[__] show or you could just sit in the
comfort of your own home you know maybe
pour yourself a glass of eggnog with
some [__] bourbon in it you know and
just sit down and binge watch all six
episodes of this cartoon get the fire
going you know what I mean turn on the
heat whatever the [__] you want to do
eat a pot
cookie and the Privacy are you're sit
there in your underwear do what whatever
the [__] you want to do or you can go
down to the goddamn movie theater and
stand in a [__] maybe you have to go
down there the night
before you
know whatever the [__] they're going to
do I
mean I don't understand why they're
still making those things other than
money Darth Vader's dead right he took
off the helmet he he died the the the
good side W it's [__] over you keep
going but what happened before the
before what about after the after
you know
listen the original hand solo was like 7
years old okay the original Luke
Skywalker he's well into his 60s you
know it's it's
over okay Star Wars people when are you
just going to admit that it's [__]
over it's like my generation can you
really sit down and watch Sesame Street
once Jim Henson was gone and hearing
that weird voice coming out of Kermit
the Frog it's it's a [__] rep it's a
[__] rap you know what I mean you
know when I like Sesame Street I like
when they're skating around on the
[__] ice just how weird that
looks how [__] tall they all are who
knew Bert was like 68 I had no [__]
idea right just out there skating around
but what I love is he's not [__]
saying
anything as far as I know I've never
been to it I've just seen the
commercials they just sort of skate
around I don't understand how they don't
think that's going to scare the [__]
their children hey I have a great idea
let's have [__] 8ot puppets skating
around with the exact same look on their
face and their eyes don't blink for
[__] an hour and a half playing weird
circus music you want to take your kid
to that well no I don't think so I I
would like my kid to become a productive
member of
society um Jesus Christ Bill all right
let's uh let's read some advertising
here for the
uh for the week and then I'm going to
tell you this story about about oh Jesus
this [__] lady who [__] I don't
want to get into it cuz I I got to put
on I put on a happy face for uh for the
advertisement what do we got this week
we got one two Uno
do all right I got
five so I'll do I'll do three and two
all right all right Dollar Shave Club
everybody um all right oh Jesus before I
get into the story about the [__]
[Music]
lady let me uh let's talk let's talk
some NFL
[Music]
football hey um so the Patriots lose
another one and I just have one thing to
say about that
wo I'm actually psyched I'm psyched that
they lost another one and you know why
you know why I am because right now I
know all of Sports Talk Radio is
completely ignoring the fact that for
the past two weeks Tom Brady has been
driving a rental car all right the
[__] Maserati is in the
shop the lambo's getting some rims put
on it right everybody thinks they're out
there beating the patriots who the [__]
is he throwing to if one more [__]
Patriot receiver twisted their ankle I
was going to be out there you know Tom
looking at me with his Steely eyes in
the Huddle I have that look of Doubt
like please don't throw it to me please
don't throw it to me
um I just I I you know I got I have too
much [__] to do I want to listen to
Sports Talk Radio today cuz yeah all
this [__] that they're going to be
talking about first of all you know what
that that gut-wrenching Bears
loss oh my God is another balding white
male I really felt for that kicker um
you know but I also like the fact that
he had the balls to just walk around
without a help on being like yeah this
is what I look like and God knows as a
[__] kicker I make enough money to
get a hair transplant but you know what
I'm playing the hand I was dealt to me
that said confidence to me said that
thing was going right through the
[__] uprights and what did he do he
[__] hooks the
thing and it goes in overtime so you
know every [__] guy on Sports Talk
Radio today is stating the obvious I'll
tell you right now you cannot give TS a
second chance and the National Football
League I mean I
me you start doing that [__] I mean you
got to hit that you got to hit that I
mean I mean I mean I
mean the playoffs are are coming up I
mean if I'm a coach of the Bears I could
not confidently say that if I get in
with field goal range it I'm not going
to go for it on fourth down after that
display I'll tell you right now if I was
a head coach of the Bears I would be
really concerned about the kicking game
because if your kicking game is not
firing on all cylinders if you're not on
the same
page if you can't dig down deep and
strap it on you're not going to win in
the naal football leue um so you know
what the Patriots right
now they're already is a hard to worry
in New
England they've lost two in a row it's
[__] great I hope they talk all kinds
of [__] about the team I I am psyched I
am psyched that we have two losses right
now it's [__] perfect as we're slowly
getting more healthy edelman's going to
come back gr's going to come back
amandola will go back to being the third
[__] choice right you know what I
mean we'll get our running backs back
hopefully we'll get a couple of
offensive [__] linemen
back and uh we'll go into the playoffs
healthy maybe even as an
underdog or at least not with the all
doing under defeated record is a [__]
albatross around your goddamn neck
everybody gets all amped up everybody
wants to [__] knock you off look at
that [__] game with the Saints
yesterday that the Panthers played
there's no [__] way the game is that
[__] exciting if the pants Panthers
come in with one [__] loss I'm
telling you it gets people extra amped
up I taped that game I I saw the
highlights I'm going to watch it today
um I like I can't even tell you how much
I'm rooting for the Panthers to go
undefeated unless they play the Patriots
in the Super Bowl but I don't I don't
think we match up well against them but
um we do obviously have the experience
but um I want to see a team go
undefeated you know well I mean there's
a couple that I don't but uh anybody
else other than like two [__] teams I
don't want to see them well was it
two I wouldn't give a [__] if the Giants
did I give a [__] if the Jets did I
wouldn't give a
ah maybe I don't think I would Seattle
would bug me Seattle just bugs me could
one more [__] talking Chimp on TV be
like right now Seattle's a team that no
one wants to run into in the playoffs
one guy said that and then 50 people
have said that I'm literally sitting on
I tell you right now Seattle Seahawks
he's the one team it's like I got it I
got
it we get it they were in the [__]
Super Bowl the last two [__] years we
get it yeah yeah they know what they're
doing who doesn't know that who wouldn't
rather play a team with a shittier
[__] coach with less exper really is
that a team that could possibly be
dangerous thank you for that
analysis I'll tell you right now I mean
they were like one play away from wining
two times in a
row and I'll tell you right now do do
not be fooled by the Seattle Seahawks
record okay they they they they they
they G up to a slow start they've had
some injuries they had a lot of they
lost a lot of talent but I'm telling the
team is starting to come together they
are starting to Jael and I'm telling you
there is an excitement building in
Seattle that I'll tell you right now I
wouldn't want to run
into here's the big thing about Seattle
if they play on the [__] road I mean
it's it's a complete I tell a healthy
Marshon Lynch comes back a healthy and
rested Maron Lynch we got it we get it
who doesn't know that they're a good
team my thing is if they're on the
[__] road there's no way they make it
to the Super Bowl if they have to go on
the [__] road they're not going to
make it you know what I mean The Only
Way Seattle is truly like Seattle is if
they're playing in their own [__]
stadium and they have all that extra
help from that stadium that makes their
fans sound louder than they really are
and I know I'm being a [__] but hey I'm
a Patriots fan if you guys are going to
question our entire Legacy cuz we stole
some signs and let a [__] hair with of
air pressure out of a [__]
ball I mean you know you play every
[__] game every oh every home game
with that Stadium I'm not going to break
your balls
back [__] unbelievable um they were
stealing signs yeah that's what you
do um
anyways I'm telling you watch the B Bor
Bears you watch when you see four people
sending in signals simultaneously you
realize everybody's [__] no no no
it's just the Patriot okay okay Santa
Claus exists he's up there right now
with those little [__] elves making a
toy for you little [__] birdhouse
right for you to stick your [__] head
in right to that little hole um anyways
but uh I'm loving the Panthers man uh
watching them go undefeated and it's
also how great is it to watch Cam Newton
come into his own and he's like you know
when Brady and pton Manning are
gone and uh I the next wave is what
Andrew
Luck uh Steve marotti whatever the [__]
his name is up there in Seattle I never
know the names anymore I used to know
the names I used to collect football
cards the guy was in two Super Bowls in
a row uh what is what his name Rayman
jeie the [__] is his [__] name all I
know is he's all I see is one story or
another about what a [__] Boy Scout
he is I actually think he's still in I
think he's in the weow at this point and
he's a football player and he actually
got into scouting after he started
playing football that's how good a
person he
is I heard he called time out last week
to help an old lady get back up to a
chair in the [__] Upper Deck that's
the kind of person that's what this kid
is made up of and I'll tell you right
now that is contagious in the locker
room
um the [__] is this I can't I can't even
[__] remember you know you got that
kid Jameson down in uh Tampa you got the
other [__] dude there on uh uh Titans
but Cam Newton's the dude
man you know that guy is the [__] we
know this what are you going to tell us
right now Seattle's not the [__] is a
team that no one wants to run into in
the [__] playoffs that's another
thing that they always said tell you
right now this is the 2 and s team that
nobody wants to
play like you what's funny is they
always say that nobody ever says I don't
want to play them can you imagine if a
coach said that after what what do you
got next week oh we got the [__] uh
we got the 2 and S Jaguars I'll tell you
right now I don't want to play
them uh coach why don't you want to play
them uh cuz they're the two and seven
team that I don't want to
play
why wouldn't you want to play the amount
of money they make per game I would
[__] play anybody I'd take an ass
kicking go beat the [__] out of me I
don't care do you realize the the Gucci
ice bags that I can [__] buy for my
body afterwards I'll [__] play in a
second my Boston Bruins my beloved
Boston Bruins are uh working their way
through a West Coast trip right now I
had to come from behind twice against
Edmonton and then Calgary to uh get one
point but uh you know they're playing
all right they're playing all right all
right I'm liking watching them um and I
got to tell you I keep threatening to do
it but I have to do it um because of a
certain team I'm not going to try and
jinx them here but I'm going to get
um I got to get the NBA package um even
if they they don't break the record of
undef the undefeated streak which I
really would love for them to
do
um you know come on man Steph Curry you
get you got I got to start watching this
guy every night like back in the day you
know what sucks is they didn't have the
NHL package so as much as I got to watch
Wayne Gretzky I didn't get to watch the
guy you know what I mean there was no
National [__] game of the week I had
to wait till like Edmonton played the
Bruins
um you know and I'd have to watch the
[__] highlights and he'd have to
score like five [__] goals for Bob
LEL to actually even talk about it um
because all they would show is basically
Bruins highlights unless there was a
bench clearing brawl you wouldn't see it
but the fact that you could watch
somebody of uh Steph Curry's greatness
night in and night out like the fact as
a sports fan that I'm not [__] doing
that because I don't want to drop a 100
bucks is uh that's it's an excusable as
Paul ver would say from the ver effect
it's
unacceptable it's [__]
unacceptable so
um anyways oh let's tell a story about
the
lady so anyways I
um as you guys know I've been driving a
Prius for a long [__] time for a long
[__] time I got it in 2007 all right
and the great thing about driving an
8-year-old paid off Prius is that it's
an 8-year-old payoff payoff Prius it's
taking all the hits it's taking all the
lumps it looks like a [__] prize
fighter 10 years after it [__]
retired you know and you just see the
scar tissue around the eyes you see the
nose has been broken you can [__]
Park that thing anyways so anyways for
years I've had that and I've had the old
68 F100 you know what I mean so the
go-to thing was um my Prius but if my
wife needed the car and I had to drive
too it became a situation because uh you
know I don't want someone to steal my
truck it's a classic car you know some
[__] out here might take it so that
there always like questions of where I
could take it at night and a lot of
times I would end up just taking a cab
so finally we've uh decided I I actually
went out and I got my wife you know I
got her I got her a car all right
nothing too fancy but nonetheless it's
[__] new and she loves it right so
now I drive the old car smart [__]
move she drives the new one she's happy
she's all cushy you know what I mean you
keep them cushy you keep them happy all
right and then when they come at you
breaking your [__] balls you just
[__] tear open the curtains and point
at the car with your eyebrows
up huh really what is the
problem then they get mad you know you
know do that just to bring it yeah you
do yeah you do um so
anyways you know me okay I don't go too
big when I'm [__] doing that [__] so
I I got you know I got her a nice
comfortable sensible [__] car you
know with a couple of gadgets on it or
whatever right so anyway so we decide
we're going to take it out last night
we're going to somebody's birthday
[__] party and uh for whatever reason
my wife goes hey can we stop off at the
supermarket and get
flowers and I go FL for what she goes
well I feel
weird you know showing up at a birthday
party without like bringing anything I
just feel like
weird I go so why would you you going to
get her
flowers like was she she's sick in the
hospital did somebody die you know what
are you getting flowers for she goes we
just shut up and let's just go to the
supermarket so I go fine I go you're
driving right so she drives we take her
car I said hey should we take the
[__] beat up Prius she goes no I want
to drive the nuke I said all right fine
we'll do that right so we drive down the
[__] Street and uh we pull into the
grocery store and I'm immediately
thinking don't park next to anybody
please don't park next to anybody and lo
and behold she doesn't she goes okay uh
she goes I take it you're not going in I
go no I'm not going in I'm not going to
stand in line watching you hold flowers
and then pay for them I'll never get
that I'll never get that 6 minutes back
in my life I'm going to sit here and
look at the scores on my phone so she
says fine so she goes into the grocery
store and all sudden this dude [__]
pulls up in his piece of [__] beat up
[__] car looks like a dinner roll
just the Classic four-door
sedan his
[__] wife is in the passenger seat
now we're faced opposite ways you know
what I mean we pulled straight uh we
pulled in you know did that thing where
there's two parking spots and you pull
past the first one and into the next one
so now it looks like you backed in but
you drove into it they came in from the
other side and parked right next to me
like me and the lady were going to start
shooting the [__] and she just opens the
door until she hits the car looks at me
and closes the door and doesn't say
anything okay and I'm like what the
[__] so I want to open the door and say
something but the [__] dude's there
and I'm so [__] mad there's no way
for me to communicate to the woman in
any sort of tone where he's not going to
then have to [__] go oh yo what's
your [__]
problem
and I just sat there and I I just
decided to just not say
anything because I've done it before and
it gets you
nowhere all they do is they go [__] you
and give you the finger and you get into
a big [__] you [__] you screaming and
yelling thing they still open the the
[__] door into your
car like what do I
do so they [__] walked in there and
it literally just like ruined my [__]
[__] evening and I just was thinking
like can you have anything nice can you
[__] have anything nice the [__]
animals there's people out there that
literally when they get out of their car
like that that's completely acceptable
to
them cuz it's all about them getting
their fat ass out of the [__] car
that they know that they've opened the
door far enough when they hit your
[__] car I had some woman do that to
me
like like 2 three years ago when my
Prius was actually still kind of new I
was actually doing a phoner or I had a
conference call and I was sitting in my
car she pulls up next to me just opens
the door into my car like boom then
closes the door walks into the bank and
I'm like what the [__] but I'm on a
conference call right talking talking
talking she comes walking back from
being in the bank opens the door boom
into my car again so I go I tell
everybody on the phone I go hang on I
should have hit mute so I put the window
down I go hey I go you just opened your
door in my car on the way in and on the
way out she just goes well did it leave
a mark and I go I don't know why don't
you look wake and I I said something
something and I told her to wake up you
know what she did she goes she gives me
she stares at me for half a second and
then gives me the finger and says [__]
you like I'm the [__] and all I did
for the rest of that conference
call other than to apologize for people
for you know having them listen to that
and then me of course looking like a
lunatic you don't want to get into
business
with all I could fantasy
about doing was [__] following her
home and just absolutely destroying her
car and I would lie to you and at some
point I didn't think about taking a
[__] extension cord wrapping it
around her neck until right before she
passed out and then let her
up that's how [__] annoyed I was you
know what I mean which is why yesterday
I'm I'm a couple years older and I was
just like Bill don't say anything cuz at
the end of the day they if they did any
damage they're not going to pay for it
it's not going to stop she's not going
to change and all you're going to do is
possibly get into a situation where the
other guy calls you out and says come on
out here so I can beat the [__] out of
you and you're not going to get out of
the car you're not going to fight this
guy you're 47 years old you're going to
go out there you're either going to lose
or you're going to win and get sued and
you're going to lose so you just have to
sit here and [__] take it and I sat
in that [__]
car just looking at their car thinking
of like I just wanted to [__]
like you know if the car was more of a
piece of [__] I would just open the car
door into their [__] door but it's a
new car so I I can't do that then I'm
like what am I going to do am I going to
kick the door am I going to do it when
they're not here that's a [__]
move you know I just there was there was
no way to win so now I'm in a [__]
mood so then we drive over to go to the
birthday party it's the wrong [__]
address now I'm in more of a [__]
mood my wife is feeling the [__]
tension so I'm [__] trying to drive
over to where we're supposed to be and
all of a sudden I can't make a left I'm
I'm in a pissed off mood [__] you I'm
taking a left as I go through the
intersection and make a left I look over
to a right what's sitting there a
[__] police car with [__] cops
sitting right in it I'm like ah [__] you
know I drive and of course he Stomps on
the gas way
overreacts the [__] drive right I was
literally [__] 10 ft away from the
guy turns on the [__]
lights so I pull
over and he goes uh do you know why I
pulled you over now he walks up he goes
do you know you can't you made a left
back there at the light you know you
can't do that I was like yeah yeah I did
I did know that I saw the sign and I did
it anyways I was mad cuz this woman
opened a door into my new
car uh and he goes all right let me see
your registration and you know we're
giving him the [__] [__] and
everything so he goes
back you know I got a big thing I don't
lie to Cops when it comes to [__] like
that do you know why I pulled you over
no no why cuz I yeah I know why I know
why you know why and I know that you
know that I know
why oh I know you know Norton so I just
say yeah yeah I know why cuz I did that
and I knew I wasn't supposed to do it I
did it anyway cuz I was in a bad mood
and he end up coming up to the car and
he was just like going all right you
know what I'm not going to write you
up but don't do that again and I said
you're going to let me go and he goes
well do you want me to give you a
citation I'm like no he goes well then
don't do it again I said all right thank
you thank you I put in the glove box
and then I drove away and I looked at my
wife and I did a fist pump and I went
white
um I didn't do that but that did cross
my mind that she was probably thinking
like cuz I want to be like you know I
wanted to brag like see that you just be
honest and I know she's sitting there
giving me those uh black lives matter
eyes so I couldn't brag in that moment
what a [__] great move I just made
you know does that make any sense all
right let me get to the questions for
the week
um I didn't do this right I do this
every [__] week with my stupid
combination I can't talk and do my
combination the same [__] time just I
just need you guys to be
quiet there it is there it
is okay here we go all right let's oh
before I get into that uh the questions
for the week let me do
um let me do the uh the last two reads
for this week all right all right
that'll be enough of that
okay now what we got here all right all
right all right oh before um before I
get into the uh the questions for this
week uh here's an opportunity to do
something nice for some people uh during
the holiday season all right children's
hospital information uh comedian Steve
Simone uh he's a comic and podcast host
on the all things Comedy Network has
been visiting the children's hospital
and spending some a lot of his free time
there uh he's had the chance to meet
some great kids really rough spots and
Steve's goal is to keep them in good
spirits and make sure they have as much
fun as any kid should have during this
time uh there are a few kids in
particular who's become particularly
close with as they need some serious
help so here we go um there's a kid
William who's battling cancer his mother
is recovering from cancer his father was
recently in a car accident and is on
disability this is not a good times
episode I swear to God this is actually
happening to somebody uh no no lie they
soon soon they're going to be homeless
all right so the money raise will go
directly towards paying their rent and
making sure they have a home at least
through the
holidays um the kid with cancer is only
4 years old he suffers from a rare
disease calls Al last week oh God this
is brutal last week he received a second
bone marrow transplant uh this Christmas
when he wakes up in the hospital you
want to have him surrounded by toys and
uh I have no doubt that Santa is real
and um actually have a home to go back
to so now that I got all the sadness out
of the way um I'm going to share a link
on Facebook and Twitter you know donate
a dollar whatever you can do we've
already raised 1,000 bucks our goal is
only three grand uh the new goal is
somewhere north of uh 10 grand if we can
so they can actually stay there for the
entire year um all the money will go
directly to the quality of life um items
for the kids no middleman we'll give
updates and uh whatever you guys donate
I'm going to try to match unless you
[__] send some ridiculous amount of
[__] money that you know what the
[__] am I supposed to I'm not going to
go bankrupt here all right but I'm going
to throw in a sizable amount of money
too um wait do we have the [__]
link oh we're going to share the link on
Facebook and on Twitter all right there
we go sorry about that guys I usually
don't do stuff like that but it is uh it
is a great thing to do um and unlike a
lot of Charities this is actually going
to go directly to the people that need
the help which is what I've always said
here on this podcast as opposed to going
into the pink [__] infrastructure and
getting reduced and then spitting out
you know a couple of coins on the other
side this is is actually going to go
directly to this uh this wonderful
family all right all right here we go
questions for the
week uh hockey and football Bill who's
your Underdog pick for the Stanley Cup
this year oh the Boston Bruins we're
going to gel right after the All-Star
break uh the underdog well you can't say
the kings of the
Blackhawks guys I'm so [__] busy I
can't I can't give you an intelligent
one I would Underdog would be uh maybe
the Canadians they definitely have the
goal tender but I just I don't believe
in the East the Eastern Conference
um I guess in Underdog I would say it
would be the Dallas Stars if they had
enough in the tank to get past well you
figure hope with any
luck the Blackhawks and Kings would face
each other and they'd knock one one of
the other out but I don't think that's
going to happen they probably be you
know top two seeds so you probably have
to go through both of
them uh yeah maybe Dallas Stars Dallas
Stars in the west and then I would say
the [__] uh Canadians in the East how
about that there's two safe picks all
right um some people think Casey oh how
about the Super Bowl some people think
Casey's D could could get them far KC's
not winning [__] they're not winning the
[__] Super Bowl Cincinnati's not
winning it they're not winning it I
think it's coming in the west I think if
the Packers I don't
know how do you not say the [__]
Carolina Panthers I know they're like a
young team but like I believe in cam
newon Swagger I don't think it's an act
like that dude in Seattle is always
jumping up and down screaming and
yelling saying how [__] great he is
to me that's a massive inferiority
complex that he that he compensates with
a huge [__] ego right I think Patrick
Peterson's every bit as good as Sherman
you know he doesn't need to jump around
he just [__] does his
job um maybe he's got to scream like
that because it's so loud in that
Stadium um anyways I like the Panthers I
believe in Cam Newton I don't think he's
afraid of the [__] moment I just
think that I'll tell you right now you
got to have a guy with that kind of
confidence you
win I I even though they're undefeated
they're not really like an underdog but
I think in a lot of ways people are
going to think that they're an underdog
because Seattle you got to respect them
they went there the last two [__]
years and who's kidding who if they
handed it off to marshan Lynch were we
really going to stop him again you know
they [__] it up they screwed the pooch
last year slash Malcolm Butler made one
of the great def ensive plays of all
[__] time um still wasn't a bad call
as far as uh considering 60% of the time
it was a touchdown the other 40% it was
like incomplete passes that was the only
interception of the goddamn
year
um and I would feel bad for Pete Caroll
but uh as a Patriots fan because he
doesn't get [__] for being a [__]
cheater uh and we do then I don't I
don't have any sympathy for them so [__]
him old Sneaky Pete he could get in
there again um
yeah I so I still think in a weird way
that the Panthers are an underdog just
because uh they are a young team um and
I'm going to be safe I have no [__]
idea what do you want me to say Tampa do
I really I I don't believe in any I
think that the uh the Patriots are in
trouble unless we get healthy
obviously uh I mean we lost to the
Broncos without [__] Payton Manning
so I think that kind of lets you know
where we're at right now
um so I don't know I [__] I I don't
[__] guys I I don't watch it to that
level I have no [__] idea what else
did he ask me
um I don't know I'm I'm really becoming
a Panthers fan though I like the
Panthers I like the Saints I don't know
what it is those
[__] is that the NFC South I don't
know what the [__] teams those are
but I I really like both of them and I'm
liking the fact that Tampa Bay is
getting
good um I don't know I like new people
that are good and I just always like the
Saints because they sucked my whole life
and I love that [__] City and I also
think the super doome is one of the
original domes out there one of the
great ones and uh I they refurbish the
whole thing and it's the [__] now it's
got the Mercedes Benz emblem on the side
of it so many of the stadiums are
jobbing.com and these [__] horrific
names they got the mercedesbenz emblem
on it that's that's the [__] so
anyways there you go how about that I
danced around that just I just expose
myself for how little football I've
watched this year I've been [__] busy
got this cartoon coming man this is my
shot all right uh car shopping Billy o
Billy I'm shopping around for a c for my
wife as well me and my friends were
talking about what the first question
should be for the salesman do you have a
first question uh yeah I'll steal what
my brother says yeah whatever his name
is hey Randy what's the real price on
this car uh he goes I feel like it sets
a precedent for the whole wheeling and
dealing my Top Choice is how much under
invoice can you sell me this
car uh I've paid under invoice it's not
a crazy thing lots of times um oh you're
saying like before the options you've
paid under that what the [__] were you
buying and when did you buy it I've
never done that my big line is what's
the out the door price and by out the
door I mean everything the warranty the
tax everything the final number that I'm
paying you and I and I just have the
number I just go I always what I always
do is I always go
I always pitch like two grand above is
it called St what not not the not the
one after all the options it's that
first number before they add the options
I always I always go two
grand um above that number now I'm
probably still getting [__] I always
get like I always get half a dick
[__] thrown my way I always do you
know um I always get [__] a little bit
but I actually enjoy the process like I
have fun with it um each time I get
[__] a little bit less like I did I
did real well on this one I felt and uh
but who knows you always feel like
you're going to turn around see them all
laughing slapping each other on the back
and then they're going to quickly stop
and uh but you know sharpen a pencil as
you look at him you know you know after
you leave but uh I I would just I don't
know read up on it watch some YouTube
videos I had I had a lot of fun this
time cuz I didn't give a [__] and I
wasn't trading in the Prius so so I just
kept saying that I just kept saying
listen dude like we'd like to buy this
car but we don't need to I mean I can
get it in that car right there and it's
drives great man it's a Toyota you know
I've kept it maintained it's all beat up
I can park it nobody's going to steal a
[__] 8-year-old Prius it's a goddamn
gem out there so I had the guy laughing
so I go look this is what I want right
so he goes and he [__] you know grab
asses with his manager and comes back
he's not even close he comes back with
this big grin on his face he goes don't
ter this this is a great deal this is a
great deal and I just go for
who for who you I mean I'm not going to
lie to you at this point if you look
around the table you're the only guy
smiling then he kind of like I I I can't
pay that I can't pay I got a check in my
pocket right [__] now I will I will I
tell my wife to you know and you always
got to send your wife if you bring your
wife is a good thing cuz they think it's
a weakness right okay and you got to get
your wife on the same page and at some
point you got to tell your wife to screw
okay you do it in a respectable way but
with a with the dash at Archie Bunker be
like honey go go uh do me a favor could
just go uh you know go look over the
cars over there blah blah you make it
look like you got this old school
[__] relationship like she actually
has dinner prepared when you come home
all right as much as your wife isn't
going to like in that moment that
feeling it works good for you in the
negotiation because now it gives this
guy the
perception that you actually are making
decisions in your relationship cuz they
buy on the fact that the emotion of the
female but I like it
right when you send them off it just be
like look I want to get this car for my
wife all right but I'm not a dope this
is what I'm paying okay this is what I
am paying I'm willing to pay this if you
get me this number I'm going to buy this
car today you're going to make a sale
and you're never going to have to look
at this car again that's the deal that's
my number
okay dude my brother's amazing at it he
always comes in his his line is he comes
in you know just he always gets the
guy's name and I feel like that gives
him power he' be like what's your name
and the guy would be like uh Stephen and
he goes Stephen you see this right here
this is a large coffee an extra large
coffee that's what he says you know why
I got this he goes cuz this is going to
be a long negotiation until I'm going to
get what I
want he comes hard right out of the
[__] gate and he's like a [__] a
comic that never stops writing I used
when we were kids we used to go down to
uh car dealerships and pretend that we
were going to [__] this is way back
in the'80s we used to
pretend that we were going to uh buy a
car so we could test drive all these
cars and my brother used to just [__]
with all these salesmen I used to do it
with him and I used to do it with
another one of one another one of my
friends one day we skipped school high
school and we went down and we said that
we were seniors in high school which we
were we said we were we were Step
Brothers it was hilar you know I had
like [__] fire engine red hair and my
but my buddy was like [__] 6'2 you
know look like a movie star all tall
dark handsome we looked nothing alike so
we said we were Step Brothers and
initially the salesman looked at us like
what the [__] and we said that uh we
were both going to be going to the same
College next year and that our parents
were going to buy us a uh buy us a
vehicle to share and they're both really
busy and they told us to come down and
uh pick out a car so immediately they
thought that we were a couple of [__]
rich kids and that we didn't know [__]
so you know we went down we took out a
chrys laser I remember we took out the
Chrysler Laser and I think that that guy
actually knew no the learon it was like
the learon I remember the big deal was
it had a digital speedometer which we
thought was [__] amazing in like
[__] 1986 or 7 whenever the [__] we
did it so um my biggest thing and and
and the thing that I learned is when you
go in there um you have to be prepared
to walk you have to know the number that
you're going to pay and
um and to definitely go in there and
have fun and uh when that when the
salesman tries to buddy buddy with you
and do all that type of [__] I mean I
don't know there's couple different ways
you can play it you can laugh along with
them or you can just kind of stare back
at them and just literally dude my
brother would literally just be like uh
like Steve I'm not here to try to like
you know listen to jokes like this isn't
a funny thing here I know what goes on
down here and I don't want to be a part
of it you understand
this is what I'm
paying and like dude how great is this
is an extra large coffee do you know why
I got this cuz this is going to be a
long draun out negotiation until I get
what I want that's is [__] classic um
all right so once again I really didn't
give you any information I I'm still
learning what to do but I I used to be
really intimidated by it but this last
one somewhere in the middle of the
negotiation on my wife's car I actually
really started having fun and realized
the power that I had
and
um I just said I'm not paying any more
than this I'm not paying any more than
this and then I got the number that I
wanted and then I I went and then when I
went to get the warranty they tacked
that on and I was like do and then they
tacked on the tax don't so I ended up
getting [__] two right there Fred so
I still got [__] but now I know I know
for the next time it's like bombing as a
comedian so I had him I had him dead to
rights and and we let him off the hook
so I still I still I I still got [__]
um but you know at least this time I had
fun um so watch watch out for that I
would just say you know know the number
that you want and make sure you just say
the out Tod door price and make sure
that you say that this includes the
warranty and all the [__] and the
tax everything this is the final [__]
number I walk out I get the car you
washed it the whole goddamn thing this
is the number you have to say that
repeatedly repeatedly um and that's
where I [__] up all right you know
what I'm man enough to admit
it all right Thanksgiving Pie Oh Billy
oh speaking of which everybody I I made
the uh the pie crust video like promised
the pie crust video has been
made um I dressed up like a
baker um we went all out so that thing
should be edited and done in the next
couple of days so hopefully towards the
end of the week um you can watch old
Billy freckles [__] make a pie crust
and and you can maybe uh I don't know
maybe show another side of
yourself maybe have that beautiful woman
you know the Sally to your hairy right
all of a sudden see you as something
else all of a sudden there's mistletoe
you know she had a slice of pie the
Sugar's going through the roof her
emotions are a little off she doesn't
know what she's thinking you move in the
next thing you know she decides to spend
her life with you right that poor
woman um you guys ever hear that tears
fears uh women woman in chain women in
Chains Woman in Chains something like
that my drum teacher was telling me
about cuz Phil Collins plays drums and
he plays this great drum Phill in the
end you know both like a minute left or
something where he just goes over the
bar line and ends on the and one it's
just classic [__] awesome Phil
Collins drum drum Phil dude that song is
the
most pandering [__] song I've ever
heard in my [__] life written by a
guy to women and General it's just like
we you're not get enough [__] at the
end of your [__]
show
H when he starts singing so free
her okay and at one point he just starts
going men are
Stone men are Stone men are
Stone unfuckingbelievable men of [__]
it's just so [__] I listen to that
song Blown Away by Phil Collins drumming
while laughing hysterically the way he
says men are Stone he sounds like he's
going to start
crying you know what I
mean I don't know I mean I got a lot of
nerve all the sexist [__] that I say but
it's just I don't that's but I mean it's
another reason why I [__] do it
there's nobody policing the other
[__] side but I guess it is a guy
doing it so I don't
know I don't he's a weird looking guy
anyways even though he's a [__] rock
star you still had to [__] you still
to put the old [__] please give me
some [__] out there anyways
Thanksgiving pie Billy boy I beged a
couple of pumpkin pies after being
insired by your recent podcast I was
invited to a friend's house for
Thanksgiving and there happened to be a
really cool girl there well let me tell
you it didn't hurt that I was the guy
who made the pies that's what I'm
telling you that's what I'm telling you
there's this weird thing about women
where they want you to be a guy but as
much as a [__] if you just show that
on some level that you can also you're
not afraid to look like a [__] I I know
what it
is it melts them a little bit he goes uh
the compliments started building up I
brushed them off like it was no big deal
that's the way you play it you go
Patrick Peterson you don't go Richard
Sherman like yeah I made those pies I'm
the best pie maker ever you don't do
that [__] you just yeah you know it's my
job it's what I do so questions came in
like do you bake a lot were answered
with no this was just a first attempt
hopefully they'll they'll get better ah
dude you're crushing it good man he goes
to which the crowd responded with get
out of here oh my God it's great oh this
dude's just reeling him in the fish are
jumping into the boat at this point I
love this guy he goes talking to the
girl later was much easier and came off
totally competent uh I thought I thought
you would say natural uh what girl
doesn't want to know/ data guy who can
pull that off thanks for the assist ah
somebody scored a goal that night
he's heating up it's going on a little
bit of a run see that I'm telling you
right now all of that stuff remember
that B I used to do what are you a fig
how guys always say that anytime you do
anything remotely like that I'm telling
you right [__] who gives a
[__] what what your guy friends are
saying okay I'm telling you right now
it's women love that [__] they love that
[__] if you have a garden I'm going make
every guy in the podcast right now be
like GH ugh just make feel uncomfortable
as a if you have a [__]
Garden right if you [__] know how to
bake what is something else you know
what I mean if you actually learned how
to sew and you sewed a button back on
your shirt I don't know how you weave
that into conversation I don't have
those skills but if they knew that you
know how to
thr like they just find that the last
thing they want is another to talk to
another [__] guy sitting there with
the tall talking about why the Patriots
it's good that they're 14 and two
basically everything that I
do yeah the last thing they need [__]
I right now [__] Seattle
no oh he's on my fantasy team like
that's
literally I I I don't I can't speak for
women but I would think that them
hearing that is literally like you
approaching a woman where you're like oh
my God she's beautiful and as she walked
up she's going like oh my God real
housewife Kardashian oh the shoes on S
and you just immediately just G your
dick just [__] starts looking the
other way like no I can't I mean I do it
who's getting who but you
know one and done one and done this is
not a home and home okay all right
girlfriend had sex with another guy oh
Jesus hey Bill I'm a huge fan of yours
from the country of Georgia not the
state all right I know where that is in
Eastern Europe um
is that that cluster of countries uh no
that's the one that Rush every once in a
while when they get annoyed they drive a
couple of tanks into isn't
it isn't that every country over there
in the Eastern block all right here we
go so here's my story I have a
girlfriend we know each other almost oh
I love these guys we know each other
almost five years and we've been friends
all of these all of these times until we
discovered our mutual love and affection
is there anything better than the way
[__] people in Eastern Europe
speak first of all they speak in English
which is tremendous that's amazing I
wish I could be bilingual I just don't
have the [__] patience um and I also
love that they don't have the word
forthe so they don't use it and it just
makes everything sound so much for so
much more direct we've been friends all
these times until we discovered our
mutual love affection four months ago
and now she is my girlfriend I study in
Poland she studies in Germany so that
means we don't see each other frequently
but we had our business time a lot I
think that's means banging each other a
few days ago my girlfriend told me that
she was on
MDMA oh that's a drug I guess but to be
clear drug did not pull the trigger for
her to make such a
thing I'm sorry man I'm trying to I'm
trying to go with your English here I
don't know I know MDMA isn't isn't that
well DMT is that one that makes you
[__] go into another dimension I
don't know what MDMA is I don't want to
know
anyways uh my girlfriend told me she was
on MDMA the previous night and had sex
with a random [__] guy she was crying
and shaming herself on the phone telling
me that she is wrong loves me I'm the
special one for her and she told me that
now it's my decision how our
relationship will go on Bill I want to
hear your advice on on these point the
thing is that I really love her and my
love is higher than that [__] sexual
act which she had with that random
[__] dude bill I want to hear your
advice and what would be your approach
in my position [__] you and eat a bag of
[__] PS love you from Georgia country
not the state and sorry for my grandmar
mistakes dude you crushed your [__]
English I can't do that I I could barely
write that well in my own my own
language all right what to do here what
to do what to do
um all right obviously my gut just says
you got to get rid of
her uh you know when you're not around
she's going to be on drugs going to
Raves and [__] a random
guy um she does give points for actually
telling you
that
uh I I
mean I I don't I don't know what to this
is hard this is hard because you said
that you actually love her and to the
level that you could look past that but
dude I would say watch casino and see
Dao's relationship with Sharon Stone I
mean do you have a potential for getting
involved in
that
um I don't know if you can forgive
somebody for that uh okay but if it
happens
again um you guys don't live near each
other
and then she goes to Raves and does
drugs and [__]
somebody um dude I think at the very
least you need to take a
break I think maybe you should just take
a break and be like I need to sort this
out and when she says why and it' be
like well because what you did [__] me
up so bad that I had to send an email to
a podcast on the other side of the
planet to try and get
advice that's why
so um you sound like you're young she
sounds like she's
young God knows there's plenty of fish
in the sea that wouldn't do
[__] whatever the [__] she just
did
ah I got to put this back in your court
dude like
just being where I'm sitting and the
fact that there's there's distance
between the two of you I just don't see
this thing working out you're you're in
Poland she's in Germany and while in
Germany goes to a party does drugs and
[__] somebody
else
um I don't know that just sounds like
the tip of the iceberg dude I think you
got to pull the
cord um that's what I would say as a
friend and I think if I was in that
situation you would say that to me too
because you weren't emotionally involved
in it however people are human they do
make
mistakes uh you know this woman better
than I do if you feel like it's worth it
give her another chance but I would sit
on this thing for about at least six
weeks uh I wouldn't have contact with
her and I would just try to get yourself
back into you and not the US
mode and after 6 weeks or
something I don't
know I I think you really gota like uh
you gota you gotta you gotta this isn't
one of those well all right you know all
right Shake It
Off um that's what I would do Okay and
like I said what the [__] do I know um
and I'm sorry that that happened to you
man that's [__] brutal um you know
I've been there and I've made both
decisions I've stayed in it and then got
burned again and I've walked and then
thought what
if so uh ah that sucks right around the
holidays too Jesus Christ
CH anyways let's plow ahead uh
girlfriend wants me to quit a uh quit
job dear Bill I'm in a very strange yet
fortuitous situation my girlfriend and
likely soon fiance inherited a large sum
of money she has asked me to quit my job
and travel with her for a
year uh I'm my
girlfriend inherited a large sum she's
asked me to quit my job and travel for a
year now yeah [__] no
no no no what you out of your [__]
mind well wait a minute what kind of job
do you have all right let me finish this
this is amazing of course however I
don't want to leave my job permanently I
have a great job in in Sound Engineering
and I'm not sure it would be available
to me after a yearlong absence yeah it
seems like a no-brainer but I'm
definitely apprehensive can you help me
we the pros and cons thanks yeah you're
going to [__] throw your goddamn
career away
for one [__] year on the goddamn D
you're going to spend a [__] year on
the road with the same
person Jesus [__]
Christ Johnny app did it solo Marco Polo
did it solo I'm telling you take a
[__]
hint dude bands travel like that for a
[__] year they travel the world for a
[__] year living their dream not
quitting their jobs and most bands don't
make it through and they're not even
involved in an intimate relationship
like you know couple thing it's a
business relationship and they don't
even make it I think to save your
[__] relationship you don't go you're
going to be [__] sick of each other
and you're going to have no [__] job
to go back to this could be the end of
your
relationship just say listen I would
love to go to it but like I mean don't
say this that other [__] I just said but
dude just be like honey not for nothing
I I don't work at a [__] you know a
juice bar I'm an engineer okay I'm
designing Bridges and [__] all
right I got a job
here that is going to that's going to
make us financially secure for the rest
of our [__] lives and I know that you
just inherited a large sum of money but
Jesus Christ where where can we put that
where can we put that legitimately
safely that we are are 100%
guaranteed to not lose it in the future
I know in my country you stick it in the
stock market Market you might as well
put it on a craft table I know you stick
it in a bank they're going to give you
half% interest and for all you know that
bank goes under and gets bought out by a
bigger bank and everybody's too big to
fail and you're in that [__] line
standing there next to a farmer with
your little [__] you know your little
book like Johnny Depp in uh that [__]
drug movie that he made the [__] was it
called Jesus Christ I saw it twice and
he gives those people all that all that
money and then they gave him a little
[__] book
he goes I gave him you know he goes I
gave him [__] whatever 10 million in
cash and they gave me a book with a
number on it and what's hilarious is
that cash represents gold that you can't
claim anymore so you just basically gave
them a bunch of piece of P the whole
[__] thing is a Lie the only thing
that you can count on is money still
coming in all right and that's what you
get with your engineering job so I would
not quit it I would not I would say
listen if you want to take a couple of
long vacations absolutely but uh you
know this is my
career and you know if she gives you
[__] it would just be like Listen
sweetheart if I if I had it if I didn't
have a career if I had nothing going on
I would do this in a second I would love
to see the world with you I would love
to spend 365 [__] days with you in a
row oh my God doesn't that sound like
fun um dude nobody is meant to spend
that much that amount of time with one
another
that they just it's nobody
is there's not a like there's nobody I
[__] know other than myself that I
could spend that amount of time with 365
days in real and the only reason why I
could do it with myself is I don't have
the option of leaving myself unless I
try and meditate you know and Float
across the [__] room you don't get
that wonderful feeling of leaving your
body and then you start thinking I'm
doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it and
then that ruins the meditative thing and
then you sucked right back into yourself
all right
all right you know what that's the
podcast everybody hey if you'd like hey
if you'd like to donate to this podcast
you know what don't don't donate to the
uh to the um the kids we were talking
about earlier that are sick this time of
year it's a great [__] thing to do
donate it give it don't give it to Bill
give it to William we're going to Tweet
the link uh that's the podcast go [__]
yourselves don't take any [__] and I'll
check in on you on
Thursday
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast uh NFL
Edition and we are talking about week
number 14 which seems absolutely insane
that we're already on week 14 Paul where
is the fall going dude I can't believe
there's only four weeks left is anything
more sad than like when you know it's
the last week of NFL and then you just
got to hope that your basketball team
does well um guys we got a great show
got some really good uh good picks got
some got some sports news that I need to
talk about before we get into this but
um before anything we have to shout out
our great sponsor it's the B MGM sponsor
everybody um you guys know how to do it
you've been watching the show for a long
time to get the best lines go to bmgm
all you got to do is download the bmgm
Sportsbook app on your phone okay sign
up using bonus code Burr that's B RR and
deposit at least $10 into your B mg
Sportsbook account place your first
wager and receive up to $1,500 back in
bonus bets J the betes yes so if the BET
loses your bonus bets will uh be
available once your initial wager is
settled guys so 10 bucks have some fun
and uh hope you're enjoying the picks it
was a very successful week for our show
um I believe nobody went under 500 bill
went three and one I went two- two I
know Andrew Jake The Snake went 4-0 Jake
The Snake went four and0 so we gave you
a total of 12- four last week guys um
but we had a rough one with that under
over for the Monday night special oh
yeah oh I watched that clip that did not
age well you're like dude Jack
Jacksonville's winning the game
Jacksonville they're winning the game
that's
what I'll tell you what I was so [__]
wrong about I saw this guy on Instagram
going like the 49ers are going to beat
the [__] out of the they're just winning
that game they're going to beat the crap
out I've never been more that's that is
the most wrong I've been about any game
of the year they weren't even in the
same class dude I haven't seen an old
school beaten like that in a long time
I'll tell you the last time I saw it
well week one my team but no when the
the no when you when it was like two big
teams oh man this is going to be a
heavyweight battle and one team just
goes no man you're not even in our class
when the Patriots beat the Rex Ryan's
Jets oh yeah we beat the [__] out of
them in December but then what happened
Paul
yeah playoffs they came back to our
house and they beat us wow now those are
two completely different teams with
completely different players but this is
a sports show so I have to act like
that's something to be concerned
about you know yeah well you know what's
funny is the the 49 historically
speaking it's 72 degrees the Jets have
not I hate when they do that the the the
49ers actually said that though the
49ers go this game is not going to be a
good game they go we're a better team
and we're going to show it and they
[__] did they did dude that was that
was like
uh that was one of those look
away I
mean dude that was one of those where
the other team looked like oh man we
have some maybe things aren't that good
like that was I tell you what blows my
mind is every time you watch an eagles
home game you always see there's like
[__] people in the crowd with the
other team's Jersey on you know what I
mean I can't believe it I don't have any
sympathy for those people no no the same
way when there's a [__] hurricane and
the Coast Guard says stay home and some
[__] idiot goes out surfing or
[__] goes you know splashing in the
waves I don't have any sympathy for you
nope stay home I wouldn't go to a any
sporting event with my jersey on away on
the road and I was talking to these
people they were Minnesota twin fans and
uh he was like a fan of my comedy he
went with his wife back in the day and
he I saw him later and he goes yeah he
goes it just kind of ruined our time we
were wearing all our twin stuff at
Yankee Stadium and people were yelling
he goes I had a red hood on a red hoodie
on and they were calling me Little Red
Riding Hood and he goes it just ruined
my time and I wanted to go like yeah man
like just wear a neutral color and enjoy
baseball like why would you do
that CA they're from the
Midwest they're drunk [__] that are
gonna [__] ruin your time dude they
they're from the Midwest they come out
there they pretend they're not racist
they don't have a oh who hell are you
have you gone to the all and they act
like they're these really nice people
they're not but mid nobody's better at
pretending that they're nice decent
human beings and people from the Midwest
but those people are out of their
[__] minds yeah you know yeah yeah
they got that those are like
uh yeah dude split slip knots from out
there you ever listen to that [__]
music that band never made sense to me
as far as where they came from until I
went to I went to Iowa in February and I
was like I get it
I get it yeah they kind of got like that
Canadian thing where Canadians act nice
but Canadians are not nice they're
really passive aggressive and they talk
a lot passive aggressive oh and the game
they embraced like is the only game that
that of the four major sports we can
just beat the [__] out of somebody and
go sit down for five minutes and keep
playing oh hey you want to have a pint
hey oh we're glad you're visiting hey
you [__] hate us if you need any if
you need any advice for some uh food
spots [__] Luna
um I got to talk about this real quick
because this is the biggest thing that's
happened to my team in a long time the
New York Yankees signing Juan sto last
night is uh as big as you could get the
one of the biggest left-handed bats in
baseball um the Yankees were like after
not making the play that's the one good
thing about being a Yankee fan when you
don't make the playoffs is they just fly
off the handle and make a move spend
money they shouldn't spent but it makes
the fans happy so uh yeah you guys got a
you got a um what's his face from us too
uh our left our left Vero Alex uh Vero
yeah yeah I didn't get a chance to watch
a lot of him is he good ball
player yeah he you know what he is too
he's also he's a great presence in the
clubhouse too he's gonna he'll
immediately be a favorite he's just he's
yeah that that was a hard one for Red
Sox fans but we've just [__] we've
watched everybody leave he was part of
the mooki bets deal so now we've like uh
got nothing out of the mookie bets deal
now we've basically I think that was The
Last Remnant of IT Major piece anyway so
uh so we start over again so you guys
are going back to what you did before
you know you tried Paul for you know
what you got I'll give it to the Yankees
you guys actually tried to win with what
you had like a lot of people you know
have done over the years you're like
yeah it's too
hard yeah I think I think Hal Stein Bren
is it h Hal Stein brener kept hearing
he's not like the old man the old man
would have [__] lost it and fired
people and they did and then they didn't
make the playoffs and I think how do you
you guys kept you must need help in
pitching though you got a couple of bats
well we got the sa young we got what's
his name had a great season in gar Cole
uh oh he did okay dude you know what was
crazy is I was in Brian cashman's box I
was in Brian's cashman's box hey stay
away from his wife okay my manager no he
wasn't in there oh okay uh and all of a
sudden I see Omar manah in there and
they got Omar maniah in there to be like
you know he was he's like a legendary SC
out and all this and he was with the the
Mets when they went to the World Series
and he's from Queens and I'm in there
it's just me and him and he's eating
sushi and he's talking and I'm telling
him I'm a comedian I'm telling him all
this stuff and we we had a great talk
I'm like dude when they put your name
through the mud on the fan like are you
and he's like no he's like because you
know what he goes I gotta when it's good
about me I gotta like take I like that
so when it's bad I'll take that right
we're talking I hear him this is amazing
actually I hear him in the you know the
way sweets are next to sweets but when
you come out the ledge you could see the
suite right next to that Suite yeah the
Yankee president Randy LaVine is down
comes down from the other suite and Omar
manah is in our suite and I hear them
talking and like the game's over the
Yankees aren't in the playoffs this is a
meaningless game we're down five runs
and I actually hear Omar Manaya say to
the Yankee president he's like yeah
they're having a business talk in front
of me as people like a few of us because
it was an empty thing except us what did
they say and he goes he goes we need two
left bats here he goes if we get two
more Lefty bats in here on this current
roster and I'm listening to one of the
best baseball Scouts tell the president
he's like we need to and then all of a
sudden I'm hearing like the sto thing
and they're trying to get another one
and I'm going holy [__] like I was
listening to this conversation and then
we get Juan SoDo so so that was your
problem the bats it wasn't pitching I
always feel if you have a bad season
it's you know it's pitching no but
what's it Cole we had um our our first
baseman uh Rizzo Anthony Rizzo was a
great Lefty bat especially for Yankee
Stadium he went down with a concussion
and he was out for months and that
losing that bat really hurt us so I
think having Lefty bats in there
especially a guy like stto who's
dangerous um yeah Paul what more do you
need you're playing a whiffle ball park
hey man I mean like how how much further
what what more are they GNA [__] do
down there and it's like yeah so let's
get some more Lefty bats you
know um just [__] with you Paul oh um
how about Paul ver shout out to Paul ver
you just named like 10 guys I've never
even heard of [__] Omar R's up there
talking to the [__] you know Mikey
Rizzo who's over there talking to the
president I haven't heard one of a scout
no Paul I don't I have a [__] life I
I don't have time to know what the
[__] Scouts names are oh people dud
you know $3 million over the cap it's
like how do you [__] know that how do
you have the time in your [__] day to
know that it's just this is all jealousy
Paul it's all
jealousy cuz the stomach flu went
through my [__] house I've been up to
my armpits and [__] [__] and PUK
there it is the old me the old me
wouldn't get to the root of the problem
God bless you Paul enjoy that new
left-handed bat you know when you're
eating your [__] uh tater tots and
down by all those [__] empty seats
nobody can
afford that stupid [__] Stadium I
remember when that stadium was built
you're like Bill it's it's almost too
much G I had to go for a walk after you
said
that did I say that yeah you sounded
like you were talking about your wedding
dress
I felt too pretty um they got Sushi and
steak Sushi you can [__] buy a time
share on the mezzanine
level that's the the [__] that Park
[__] sucks because Yankees the old
Yankee Stadium had the one of the
greatest most iconic [__] sounds in
the playoff when MLB would mic that
[__] thing up and you guys would
start cheering with two strikes I I mean
I hate as a Red Sox fan to say it it was
[__] iconic and now they have it's
like $9 million per seat you guys look
like you're in last place even when
you're in first place there's nobody at
the game I gotta blow my nose I
apologize I don't like the stadiums that
are open the whole way around it used to
be you walk through the [__] tunnel
or you walk through that thing and then
you see the field it was like the field
was this magical thing that you had to
get to and now when you get in the
stadium you can see it all around I will
say this though the 1923 replica of how
it exactly looked when you're sitting I
do like and I like the facade on the
side I do like that I like that they put
the facade going back around the thing
yeah that was that was good let's not
[__] on the whole thing um all right
let's go I got my first pick here first
pick for week 14 I went two and two the
last three week put a mall out in right
field at
Fenway what happened oh that was the
patriots the patriots built a mall next
to their Stadium Patriots Place Paul you
want to go buy a polo
shirt uh I think about when I think
about football I go you know what I need
to buy some socks Tom Brady's tb12 store
at the
[__] all right Tom vers
time all right man this is uh I like
this week's numbers I like this week's
spreads oh Paulie likes it Paulie likes
it I like this week's spreads um I think
you know my first pick
here I'm going to take the Philadelphia
Eagles on the road against the Cowboys
they got really humiliated last week uh
you [__] [__] I like that pick
they're getting three and a half dude
and I just think after dude if they get
this [__] kicked out of him by the
Cowboys you got to put Nikki on [__]
suicide watch oh dude dude that guy you
know what I love about him he [__]
feels feelings yeah he does that guy has
his heart on his [__] sleeve like if
he was in platoon he's that guy I got a
bad feeling about this one
man I give him credit though man he
wasn't like walking off fast he gave the
the other coach a hug and said nice
things I just love that he's always
yelling at people it's like the game
before it's start [__] you we're gonna
[__] kill you and then he's walking
out the Chiefs fans yeah you're not
saying [__] now are
you why did they make that fat dude oh
and he nodded at the camera dude I'm
telling you this guy the more I watch
him the more I love love him he's like
[__] he's one of those guys like his
wife's going like like Nick don't take
the bait just come on honey don't take
the bait I'm I'm going to be cool today
I be cool today loving him is a little
strong I think you know I love a man
that struggles with his emotions I
relate to
him um no he said nice things to Kyle
Shanahan he hugged him hey great job but
you know dude I'm gonna tell you
something right now if the Eagles go and
[__] lay an egg in Dallas it's I
don't think that's going to happen I'm
taking them three and a half a little
bounce back after a national
humiliation oh yeah dude that was like
that was a day that we live in infamy um
all right so you took one of my favorite
picks of the week uh you know what Paul
I'm GNA keep riding this Packers train I
say the Packers going there I love their
quarterback I love what they did next
week last week the way they hung with
the Chiefs actually beat the Chiefs
um I know they're laying six and a half
I know they're they're in the Giants but
I mean what do you guys you got [__]
uh Anthony maruchi [__] Tommy cutlet
Tommy cutlet playing [__] quarterback
there you know you know you guys you
guys can't stay away from the club on a
Friday Saturday night come on you know
he's going
[Music]
out uh you know he's gonna wake up have
a little [__] Sunday gravy I I like
the Packers six and a half late six and
a half this is a smoothie by the way I'm
not drinking chocolate milk like a
little boy that I am I'm gonna have fun
with you I'm gonna have fun with you
this week cuz I was actually for the
first time in the history of our
show of our amazing Sports football show
I was going to do something that Paul
ver has never done before and what I was
gonna do is I was gonna take the Packers
against my Giants for the first time
ever I was gonna go against my Giants
because it was going to be a game that I
couldn't lose either I win the game or
my team wins but then I said you know
something I'll go head-to-head with you
on this one bill I'm gonna take Tommy G
to beat the book no dude I'm don't fall
on the knife what do you mean I'm up
it's just it's your [__] Paul the
fans know what have you're a real fan we
know it you're a Nick fan diard Nick fan
you're a DieHard Giants fan you're a
DieHard Yankee fan we know this you
don't have to prove
this I gotta go Tommy cutlets on Monday
Night Under The
Lights I got you know who he is you know
who he is he he's he's your new [__]
uh what's his face there
uh dude what's with my I'm going say
Gino capetti who's the [__] guy that
was the guy the 49ers and then the
Raiders good looking Italian kid garoo
this is your new garoo Paul bery cannot
lay off an Italian American quarterback
I can't you just can't he starts hearing
the Sinatra music oh and then they start
giving him nicknames with food it's over
Dude Tommy cutlets that's over I think I
think the Packers could win the game
maybe the Giants hang with him and get a
little back door you know what Paul I
think ate too much Noki last night I
don't I think you got you got [__]
potato brains right now um oh boy all
right what am I going with next you know
I want to know why why the [__] are the
the Chiefs only favored by one and a
half points did somebody get hurt Jake
The Snake where are you Jake anything
happening out there I don't think so I
saw that very suspicious Chiefs are
coming off a loss against the Packers
the bills they they they know it's
[__] over it's only a one and a half
you GNA tell me that those guys aren't
going to get get it done that [__]
Patrick Mahomes isn't going to run
around like a reindeer like he does
there Paul on his tippy
toes I'm I'm gonna go with the Chiefs
I'm going with the Chiefs Paul you're
going with the Chiefs all right I'm
going with the
Chiefs uh you put that down of the book
I've watched too many jets games where
they just have a no offense no offense
it's it's they're on their third
quarterback it's a mess in New York
media they don't know what to do the
coach is saying this the other
quarterback's saying this they're
talking about people getting fired the
Texans are on fire and they have a
quarterback how can you fire their
[__] coach dude Aaron Rogers went
down they made the move this is just a
bad luck year the fact that the [__]
New York media is eating this guy
alive I mean from day one the [__]
head of the snake got chopped off what
what are they supposed to no that's true
but there's really penalties that are
like when you're your penalties are bad
dude they're a bad team they're
undisciplined team they're a team that
gets a pick six and gives up a pick I
mean it's [__] is Paulie Giants talking
no no no I mean listen Paul that defense
has been on the field the whole [__]
year yeah they're a little frustrated
they're taking some dumb things there's
there's psychology involved here this
isn't all analytics no Paul I'm wearing
a satin jacket you got to listen to me
and it's shiny and new well you know
what it is it's [__] it's the
lighting in here dude it's popping dudee
I look like I jumped in a swimming pool
with this
jacket I was home the whole time I'm
gonna take the Texans minus three and a
half I think the Jets are
phito you want to talk about fenito was
watching the [__] charges Patriots
game oh I just sat there Paul on the
couch I don't think I moved the entire
game it was six to nothing I was just
sitting in the corner going
I remember this and then they were
wearing the old Pat Patriot uniforms
which when they bring them back can you
come go with the black cleats too let's
go all the way back to the AFL what are
we doing here Paul um all right Paul I I
don't have a good feeling about this
week because this next pick I don't know
why I'm doing this why would you do this
that's why I feel about my Giants pick
but hey you what that's how I feel about
my Giants pick I don't you know I'm just
I'm just I'm doing that one for for
fun Chargers won six to nothing the
Broncos are getting three points I think
both of these teams are very evenly
matched it's a division rivalry game
they're getting [__] points Bill
loves a Division I can't [__] figure
out the [__] Broncos I
know and I just don't understand what's
going on with
Russell like how how do you drop off
like that
um fing and Raiders man we got a bunch
of [__] like this week feels like 2:
a.m. in a bar you know like what am I
going home with
here I like when you think that like you
weren't part of the problem like the
chicks weren't looking over at you
like yeah I mean I guess I'll [__] him
um all right so you took the Texans that
was something I was going to do you know
something just for the fun of it Paul
I'm gonna take the Ravens I'm gonna take
all [__] favorites this week oh my
God you [__] can't stop with the
Ravens dude well you know what it is
Paul the [__] the the the the Rams
covered last week the Rams are very
erratic and I don't think they're good
on the road especially when they get out
of the division and they play an AFC an
AFC team from Baltimore historically
speaking and they're coming RS get out
of their division and they go to
Baltimore yep and Baltimore's home
coming off a buy they're a little rested
up yeah yeah I feel like you know
they'll have a little little spark in
their step seven points why not hey Paul
Why not start the game down seven
nothing hey Bill who are you who who am
I I'm I'm
nobody all right here we go I'm gonna do
this just because I saw this kid play
last week um I watched Browning play for
the Bengals uh Joe Burrow's backup and
the kid was sharp as hell he he they got
Joe Mixon running the ball like a mad
man they got Chase T Higgins is back
Boyd is one week oh Paulie one week he
sees a guy one week and he you you want
to crown him go ahead and crown him no
no it's actually this actually his third
week now coming up no he did play great
and he played really good and the coach
they rubed his balls all over all those
[__] network shows Paul so you got to
be thinking that other defense is they
might they might take exception to that
look what's his name muu what's M's name
Garder mchu I love Gardner mchu Gardner
mchu he's they're flying high over there
but the line is one I would probably go
the other way if it wasn't in ciny but
it is in ciny they're coming off of a
win and they got a lot of talent minus
one it's basically a pick them so I'm
going to take the home team with a pick
them after a win and see if this kid
Browning could throw a couple wins
together you know what the way you broke
that game down you convinced me I think
that's a good pick here's my question
Paul is uh Trevor Lawrence still out
like what happened to
him Trevor Lawrence is out for weeks
with a uh it wasn't broken his ankle but
he's got a high ankle sprain he's
probably going to be out until the
playoffs H I feel bad for all the ladies
in Jacksonville you know they
Andrew can't hear you man you're on mute
sorry they said two weeks for him two
weeks
yeah yeah week 17 and uh Joe flacko Paul
I thought that guy retired five years
ago Dude Joe flacko coming out of
[__] nowhere I believe in Joe flacko
minus three at home oh you [__]
[__] I hate this week I hate this
week
my lions are going to the
Bears now I'm worried nothing worse dude
last week when I bet the [__] lions
and they were up 21 to nothing I go
finally I got a [__] easy game right
and then like here come the Saints they
all just come [__] running back dude
I'm telling you Paul this didn't
happen when I was a kid the way blowouts
last there were blowouts last week
dude Paul you keep saying saying that
there were though Paul I'm not talking
about there was blowouts when I was a
kid you know what a blowout was being
down 21 nothing in the first [__]
quarter you didn't come back from that
right that was a historical comeback
every [__] week I I I'm I'm betting
on something my voice is cracking over
here Paul yeah me I'm opening up to you
we were we were talking about this on
text I think there's just there's a lot
of bad teams that [__] don't know how
to close a game like that pre well you
don't think that they've changed the
rules
so much so that no game is ever Out Of
Reach no game is ever Out Of Reach now
that games were [__] over with a
quarter to go when I was a kid you know
what happened Paul people shut the
[__] game off and they didn't watch
the
commercials so the advertisers is like
what the [__] if this is a blowout we
should have a little little thing here
in the contract that I don't have to
[__] pay if nobody's watching they
used to they used to switch the game off
throw you to somebody
else now all of a sudden Paul Paul you
telling me out of 33 [__] 32
quarterbacks like [__] 27 of them are
Joe
Montana no I'm looking for gardam
muu it's hard to hear that name and not
uh no offense to him but dude there's
not a quarterback in the league that
cannot cannot have an amazing fourth
quarter comeback now that was not the
case when I was coming up it was [__]
John Elway Joe Montana there was like a
handful of guys that could do it and
everybody
else I don't know Paul maybe maybe maybe
maybe it's the video games yeah I mean
look man they they definitely do like
makeup calls and [__] like that but I do
think the better team like like I really
thought the Shocker for me was I thought
the Eagles and 49ers were going to come
down to like a PA I have a shocker for
you a what I got a shocker for you I'm
gonna take the Seattle Seahawks getting
10 and a half points division rivalry
going down there they always play him
it's always a [__] tight game oh I
think 49ers are walking around they're
sucking their own dicks all they're
waiting for is like a Cowboys they don't
give a [__] about the Seahawks Seahawks
aren't a threat to them they're going to
come in there you know [__] lean it
to the side a little bit you know
they're still gonna be taking off their
[__] jewelry and it's already going
to be [__] 10 to 10 at halftime I'm
telling you if there's two things I've
learned about you since we've been doing
the show is Bill loves a sneaky Peete B
and he loves the raaven bits games yeah
I mean Paul why you why you acting like
you don't have Tendencies oh I do I'm
the Chargers before the before the show
started this morning when I was looking
at the lines I saw those two games and I
like the Seahawks getting all those
points and I was hoping bill would I
didn't say anything before the show but
I was I swear to God I I think I started
to tell Jake I was really hoping bill
would take both the Seahawks and the
Ravens I swear to God I was like these
this is the week that bill
just Fu finally my my theories come
together they finally come together Paul
don't take that personally I saw you you
look down
for everybody here which is why I don't
know why you went head to head no no no
no I'm saying I'm saying you're starting
the game with 10 and a half points and
you know the Seattle Seahawks are
desperate I mean that's a game that like
you should that's a good one that's a
great pick that's all I was saying
that's great that kid on on on on
Cincinnati that wide receiver that
caught that ball and took off and looked
like DK DK metf there's like [__]
five or six receivers in the league that
have like Dion Sanders
Chase was it t Chas I don't know oh oh
Chase is
amazing he's got the perfect last
name no that's why I that guy was like
crossing the goal line and he was still
separating from defensive backs like if
I was an NFL team I'm looking for the
next Daryl green like who isn't but like
Beyond his covering ability Daryl
Green's speed like
um these guys nowadays like like DK metf
is like the guys are [__]
Terminator no that was n he should not
be that size running that fast it's
terrifying it was it was ridiculous
um the Patriots could have drafted
him
really
yeah he was on the board yeah yeah he
was on the it's easy after you see the
guy crush it I hate when people do that
how the [__] did you take this guy after
that guy you know why because neither
one of them played an NFL game and I
think DK was hurt someone was telling me
he was hurt his senior season he went to
Mississippi m s i you're making me sad
dude you know what that made me think
about oh it hurts it's the Hat Paul you
know I love you to death please don't
make don't please don't be sad during
the holidays no dude the Hat I'm wearing
now we were a pick away from the story
of the Knicks isn't so much that they
leave people on the board they have the
story about the Knicks is we're one pick
after the pick and the pick before that
we that we missed by one pick was Steph
Curry Steph Curry was seven dude and we
had eight or whatever dude your voice is
Steph Curry was seven dude if Steph
Curry
oh all you could do is just look up and
God and go all right I got worried when
you said you're sad because being sad in
April is all right but being sad in
December that's when you really got to
like keep an eye on your friend you
know you know why I'm not sad you know
what made me out of I sad the gift that
keeps on giving everybody when you feel
like it's absolutely over the New York
Yankees give you a gift with a bow on it
and says Ah we'll see what we can do
with
this we getting all you suckers to go
buy some tickets yeah it's true um all
right oh we got to talk about one team
that you mentioned and we talked about
this I know our picks are over are the
Miami Dolphins for real or are the Miami
Dolphins blowing out teams because their
line this week is minus they are minus
13 and a half against the Tennessee
Titans they are absolutely obliterating
teams that are around 500 or less and
they're struggling against teams that
are better struggling they've lost to
everybody they lost to the [__] bills
they lost to the Ravens they lost to the
Niners and they lost to the Eagles
they've lost to all they didn't lose to
the Ravens though I think they play the
Ravens on New Year's
Eve Oh I thought they lost to the Ravens
they lost to a yeah they dude they I
finally sounded like I knew what I was
talking about I'm so you know what with
that jacket today I shouldn't have even
said that I should have just let you
go I love the jacket I love the team
regardless of their [__] record what
are you gonna do um are the Miami
Dolphins going to get a big surprise in
the playoffs bill or what yes all right
dude I think you know I think they could
win one week but I just don't think that
they're
they're they're you know they're not
beating the
Chiefs I don't think they are Paul this
standup comedian says that that
professional Fran football franchise is
not being this other football
franchise um dude the Baltimore Ravens
the Baltimore Ravens are going to be a
[__] problem I think I think the
Baltimore Ravens may be there in the AFC
Championship game I don't know man that
that kid is good I think the Ravens I
think the [__] Bengals if they can
make it in could be a problem for
somebody they have a great defense and
all of a sudden this kid's playing all
right yeah Joe burrow man that would
have been you don't want to play a
[__] team with a really good defense
in the playoffs you just
don't uh was that Paul huh you ever
thought you've never had that thought
before really Bill Oh I thought I
thought you wanted to play a [__] you
don't want to play a team with a bad
defense hey I tell you what you guys
don't want to play a team with a good
wide receiver good running game and a
decent defense in the playoffs you do
not want to see that team good
quarterback you know a lot of people
don't think you need a good quarterback
to win but I'll tell you this
Paul you know and I I'll I'll take the
hits on social media I'll tell you what
dude you need a franchise level player
at the quarterback position yeah you
know what listen I don't know would
build my offense around it that's just
me yeah I mean I don't know much but
I'll tell you what you do not want to go
against a good experienced coach in the
playoffs all I'm
saying you don't want to I'll tell you
what you really want to a stacked
team okay with Gamers at every
position by the way Paul who do you like
between Michigan and
Alabama you know I watched Alabama in
that Georgia game oh by the way Andrew
themess just said Ravens looking better
against the Chiefs in the AFC champ yeah
I mean that's going to be if if it's
Ravens chief AFC Championship Game Dude
I think gun to my head I think gun to my
head I'll take Baltimore Dolphins Jake
The Snake Dolphins haven't beaten a team
over 500 in two years wow see you know
that's why Jake is hired you know Jake I
mean you're earning your money Jake you
know what it is Paul you know what it is
about the dolphins dolphins are like
that [__] six that puts on a bunch of
makeup and a wig and [__] me pumps and
all that that's that's what they are
okay and then you get her home and she
starts taking everything no they're all
tits no ass it's
like that's
perfect dolphins are all tits no ass
that's [__] perfect we got to keep
that one that's a Paul verism right
there
go yeah you know you show up you see hey
Paul Paul there's a lot of pain on that
house um I saw dude I saw what Alabama
did to Georgia man and I gotta be honest
I was really impressed with how Alabama
I mean I know that turnover that the
quarterback with Georgia dropped the
ball and he didn't even know that [__]
them up but um Michigan's good dude
that's a good game man that's a good
game who do you like Alabama it's just
gonna it's going to come down I think
they both have uh you know unbelievably
talented players both great programs but
at the end of the day it's Nick
Sabin it's Nick Sabin they're gonna get
him sec versus the
uh what Big 10 the Big 10 Big 46 but
they still call it the Big 10 yeah and
usually the SEC is better right better
competition in that uh
conference um it's well I mean you you
like you're dealing with Nick Sabin it's
like if if you're a number one pick
coming out of high school in Alabama
calls you're going so he's just what the
program that he's built there
people know that you're going to be
playing on a n National TV you're going
to get all this exposure and you're
going to win championships so they
basically you know I feel like because
of that at every position their player
is would be you know they they have guys
on the sideline that would probably be
starting at most colleges and then the
they're the number two backup I just
think like the level of
uh because I've you know I with the kids
I can't watch as much as i' like to but
like I've I've seen a few games and like
some guy goes down you're like oh my
they're like oh this is a big thing for
and this next guy comes in and it's just
there's no drop off well the perfect
example of that was Jaylen Herz and Tua
were the quarterbacks at Alabama at the
same time that's like two quarterbacks
killing it in the NFL where they both
they both played there yeah sa Sabin
took out Herz and put In Tua and Tua
came in and threw a touch at a national
championship I mean it's like yeah yeah
it's it's a it's a minor league NFL team
what Alabama is but um I don't know it's
going to be good but as far as like the
rest of the SEC obviously Georgia's
really good but you know then you got
you know like they're upper at Shalon
there's always like a couple of teams
that could pretty much you
know I don't know that it's a different
you know it's more I feel like it's more
of an NFL style where it's to the air
where where Big 10 is more
Smashmouth yeah kind of football and uh
I don't know I'm I'm in over my head on
this one I don't think the Big 10
historically speaking of in the last
like 15 years has done well against the
SEC I don't think I remember Ohio State
one
year was just a [__] the year they
won the championship I think they beat
an SEC team like look I say like LSU
even like the great LSU
teams you know I don't think we're we're
at the level of a great Alabama team um
this Alabama team's kind of struggled a
little bit I [__] Nick Sav dude it's
Nick Sav I just you know I'll never
forget that game we went to Alabama LSU
uh at LSU and uh the last last minute
Alabama got a touchdown that place was
filing out no that was LSU LSU [__]
coached the way until like that's the
thing the difference between having Nick
Sabin not having Nick Sabin it's Auburn
Auburn had him [__]
beat make a mental mistake you drop a
[__] Punt and then you [__] Rush
two on the final play of the [__]
game and the guy standing back there for
25 5 seconds with all A-list [__]
wide receivers how long could those
Corners cover him yeah yeah some point
you're looking back like what the [__]
and you lose sight of the guy for half a
second now not taking away from the
quarterback because that guy threw a
[__]
Dart um why do you think certain coaches
like Nick
Sabin aren't successful at the NFL but
in the in the college do you think it's
just because they know how to deal with
kids better than than dudes that are
making millions of dollars and don't
want to hear your [__] like there's more
of a motivational thing for a young
person I would ask a a guy that coached
at both levels I have no idea but I will
say that I think being a
college um coach as far as Personnel is
way more different you can't lock a guy
down in in in the NF in the uh college
football these guys stay for [__]
couple years especially College hoop
these guys are all one in 10 these big
guys and so it's like you it's not like
you know
back in the day when you got your AEM
elijuan it's like we got this kid for
four years he would have been a oneand
done yeah have him for one year and then
the next year you got to try to find
another one so
uh I don't know but I I would say that
the
it with my limited knowledge college
football seems really difficult to me to
stay successful for a long period of
time um or maybe the kids just want to
go if you're successful if you have a
successful program but but the proof is
in the pudding because most of those
guys that dominate look at that Ohio
State guy he [__] you know destroyed
Michigan for the first 20 years of this
decade goes to the NFL and just [__]
flamed out ended up in a Hooters with
some chick on his dick right oh yeah
yeah what the hell was that guy's name
uh Urban Meyer Urban Meyer yeah so I
mean yeah Nick sa but also like you're
coming up you're going to go from
Alabama to the Cleveland Browns or the
the
Dolphins yeah I I I have a theory on it
I think that you motivate a young
student athlete to be better than they
thought they could be and they'll run
through a wall for you and you call a
guy over and you go hey man I want to
give you a chance I want to get you off
the bench and you lift the guy's spirits
and he'll [__] do anything and then
you go to the NFL and you tell a guy
that knows he can [__] do it and he's
just like yeah dude I don't need to [__]
how about the [__] how many people
keep coming at bill bich this latest
thing this latest thing they coming at
him for is his [__] coaching
tree I get that but which has Nick Sabin
in it which has who gives a [__] about
his coaching tree and here's another
thing if the coaches Underneath Him
didn't do [__] doesn't that make him
seem like an even better Coach but then
when you talk about that oh it's all
it's all just Tom Brady you know what it
is Paul there's just a bunch of [__]
haters out there that's all they do yeah
um well number one you blew over my
theory which I thought was a good one
what was your
theory no I I didn't even listen to it
Paul I'm so self involv my no my my
college coach thing I actually agree
with what you just said about bich I
think the fact that bellich che's
coaching tree fails or the guys under
his under him fail is because it shows
him that he's
better like yeah like uh who the [__]
who's Don schulas I don't know who that
coaching tree is yeah they [__] Romeo
kenell went to the Browns and everybody
thought it was going to be good I
remember saying something oh you got
that guy somebody's like uh we'll see
dude do you judge a comedian on who used
to [__] open for him right yeah it's
true I saw that I saw that I just wanted
to see your face do that that silent
like I used to open for Bill I was like
well I haven't you know open for a while
um it's
hilarious you're my biggest success you
know what's crazy about the bellich
stuff is how I I've literally heard
people say he's done and it was Brady
and then be like yeah but you know what
I'd take him I'd love it if he took the
I'd love it if if he moved to came to
the Chargers like you hear that so it's
like everybody who thinks he's washed up
it's like yeah LeBron's not what he used
to be whatever but we'll take him you
know what I mean that's the thing about
Tom Brady Tom Brady leaves the Patriots
then he goes window shopping around the
league to find the best situation I mean
belich could do
that no yeah and dude at what point is
coaching adab bellich cheek's heart how
long you going to do it was a man is a
man almost 80
I mean how old he just broke up with his
like longtime wife girlfriend dude this
guy's gonna they're gonna be Wheeling
him over what are you talking about he's
probably get stem cells right now what
you think when is it out of his heart
Paul what heart what are you talking
about this man's mind it's dude is he 70
how old is Bill bich he's got to be over
70 than Pete Carol he's younger than
Pete Carol is he yeah he's a year
younger than Pete Carol dude Pete Carol
is the guy he's taking the The [__]
Dick Clark HGH dude that guy does not
age P Carol is amazing he's chewing his
Gum as fast as ever he's running up and
down the sidelines he's clapping he's
that's why his jaw he still has a jaw
he's [__] chewing that gum like Mike
Mike dco always chewing the Gum as the
jaw um hey you gotta start chewing some
gum okay yeah you know here's the thing
though man Florida State getting [__]
13 and0 I'm glad they're going to a
deeper playoff next year where more 12
teams make it cuz you know A System's
broken if a college football team like
Florida State goes 13-0 and they're not
in broken there's 2,000 [__] teams
what are they supposed to do yeah but
I'm talking about an undefeated team
can't miss something dude yes they can't
Paul they beat everybody they got in
front of them what are you talking about
what are you talking about what do you
mean things fail all the time 13-0 dude
yeah what are they special but what do
you tell them hey you're the only team
to ever be undefeated there's not enough
there's not enough [__] room remember
when the Choppers left Vietnam there was
people [__] hanging on the skids
falling off this is what the world is
like
there's never quite
enough I know you pull up to these
[__] stores out here Paul the store
can hold a 100 people there's like
[__] 10 parking spots that's what
life is but who deserves a parking spot
the handicap
guy I don't know if that makes even
sense who's staying home all the
time um all right we got a we got
handicap people stay home more than
regular people or is it just so [__]
obvious when they do and how come the
handicap spot are always open when I go
into a thing they're always there and
then go one time I took one one time I
took one I couldn't handle it I circled
four times I go [__] it I'm going in for
five minutes and I did it what you gon
do um I only did it once Jesus Paul I
only did it once Jesus Paul there were
seven spots Bill nobody was taking them
I circled four
times um well how do you know one of
those wheelchair basketball teams wasn't
going to pull up to get a [__]
[Laughter]
slurpie they all drove separate car cars
like [__] swingers that's how scared
of my wife I was that day her calling
going what what's taking so long like ah
[__]
it um all right I guess we're getting
the hint from the you I would have
defended you in that story but I know
your sense of direction so I'm on your
wife's side on that one what's taking so
long you should have been like what do
you mean what's taking so long I get
lost in Manhattan the [__] streets
are numbered dude I gotta tell you
something before we get our producers
are telling us to hurry up and go to the
Monday night special but before I do
Bill I walked out of my hotel room dude
I was thinking of you when I did this
the two people that laugh at me the most
are you and you and Giannis just Giannis
just goes dude I've never see he's like
it's shockingly bad I walked out of my
hotel room and I went the wrong way to
the elevator and I stopped in the middle
of the hallway and I turned and I go how
did I I just couldn't get my bearings
dude it's something somebody goes oh you
have Direction dyslexia and they go
that's a thing and I go what is that and
they go yeah you just can't figure it
out I like all right yeah dyslexia has
nothing to that would be like you I
guess you only read signs and you can't
see what they
say um all right let's get into the
Monday Monday night special yeah it's
like being toned deaf you know you can
take all the singing lessons you can
you're not going to be able to sing a
song This directions is not your thing
no it's not you know you're just a
traveling comedian I just don't I don't
think it's G to come up that much oh my
God Paul you're so [__] lucky they
have GPS now oh dude do you imagine can
I imagine I lived it I got a plane one
timey late drove 80 M an hour in the
wrong direction for a [__] hour and a
half I had to drive 80 back just to get
to where I started and I got a [__]
ticket on the way I told you that story
the guy the [__] cop pulled me over
he was in his car he had a little bubble
he got out the only part of the cop
uniform was he had the shirt and he had
like tucked into Wranglers I was in the
middle of [__] nowhere I was going
like is this guy gonna kill
me he came up and he punched my window
he goes get it out
Fel I was in a Cohen brother movie all
right let's let a Monday night special
win some money for you all right we got
Giants and Packers and both of us picked
the other team we got an under over of
36 we got the Giants getting six and a
half we got Jordan love playing
quarterback on the other team we got
Tommy Cutler playing quarterback on our
team sequan Barkley's in the game
there's a lot going on here I don't
know what do you think
uh I think the Packers I think love
throws
one and what's the under over the under
over moved to
37 oh I was going to say because I
thought it was going to be
low 37 we do we could
do7 I think Giants get an interception
can we do that or no you shouldn't be
allowed to do a Monday night special
when your team is
playing no no dude I'll do I think
saquon's going to get 245
yards you want to do a saquan yards
thing or what do you want to
do um over under just moved to 37 okay
Pete Carroll's 72 bill bich is
71 and those are oldest in the league
right yep wow all right so the line move
from 37 to
36 so that means money's on the
over um i' take the over you want to
hear some player props uh right now it's
like Tommy DeVito you can get him uh you
know over under
150 that seems like where they're kind
of starting 150 is pretty low i' I'd
still probably take the under I don't
think he's gonna put up 150 150 yards
passing yeah dude who's he gonna th I
mean yeah that's that's Tommy DeVito
what' he have last week I mean dude 15
DeVito sounds like some kid in detention
Paul oh yeah I told you to stop hanging
out with that goddamn Tommy
DeVito wherever Tommy goes Trouble
Follows dude 150 yards passing on Monday
Night Football dude he should do that I
mean Jake what do you
think it's a low number I mean it's hard
to say hard to say he could dump he
could dump a pass to saqu saquin goes
for 30 yards with that I'm sick of you
talking about saquin like he's burning
up the league he isn't yeah
it's but he was hurt dude he was hurt
for three games yeah but there's no
chemistry between him and DeVito at this
point you know how many you how many
good quarterbacks right now are not
hitting good what do you mean he gave
DeVito the Tommy cutlets nickname and
hugged him and said I love you all right
so they had a good lunch what do you
want to
do God oh Paulie chemistry Paul Paul
loves the uh what's Bill Paul I picked
two I'll let you pick the last one what'
you pick love to throw I got Jordan love
to throw one I got the Packers to cover
six se seven well they yeah yeah so you
you got what when the [__] did it go to
seven this was six and a half the
beginning of this podcast no no got a
win by seven I'm saying all right um you
say seven Paul now I gotta win by
[__] eight yeah dude saquon Barkley's
getting a touchdown in this game Monday
football Jo at the at the stadium I mean
there's no I I would put I would [__]
I would bet a lot on it okay I'll bet
you 50 bucks he doesn't
what yeah damn all right a side bet okay
I bet you 50 bucks he does it San
Barkley gets a touchdown Monday night
saquan not saquan sequan Barkley don't
tell me how to say my favorite player's
name well you [__] always talking
about the
guy dude where does he R guys I mean
he's not burning up the Le league but
he's for a guy that missed a bunch of
he's on a bad he's a great [__]
player on a bad team that's why he keeps
getting [__] hurt all right it's deep
in the season that guy has taken a bunch
of [__] two and 11
hits no you're right I I you know what
you stopped me in my tracks because I
thought about when he got hurt it was
they stopped him up at the line of
scrimmage you're right bad off offensive
line he'll [__] you up
um all right so you got to get fat guys
that can move
Paul just having people that are fat is
not an offensive line it's true it's
true you got to care how much you
[__] eat as long as you can move all
right I gotta meet somebody at 1045
let's wrap this up what do we got here
so we got Jordan love to throw one the
Packers to cover Sequon Barkley to get
an anytime TouchDown for your Monday
night special we don't [__] with the
under over and me and Paulie got a side
bet 50 bucks just make it fun bucks that
saquan gets a touchdown Monday night
that's our side bet Paul I I hope I lose
you know hey because then that means I
get to take you out for a steak dinner
there you go there you go Paul it's 50
bucks you should have been where the
[__] are you taking me
[Laughter]
tads um all right guys there you go
those are our week 14 picks Monday night
special Jordan love to throw one Packers
to cover saquon Barkley for a touchdown
anytime we hope you win bet responsibly
uh deposit $10 into the account you'll
get up to $1,500 in bonus bets uh so go
to the betmgm app download it to your
phone and have a good time with us there
you go week 14 we got three more of
these dude and the season is fenito um
hey what's our records right now I
picked up two games so what am I like
four under 500 you're one game
under how is that possible I feel like
I've just been sh you know I just went
two and two every week you were no dude
you had two dude you're what you're
doing this like you don't even realize
you've on week 14 you've had two games
that were under F two weeks that were
under 500 dude that's like nuts I know
but I've only had two games over uh no
but no I've had one and three one and
three and last week I went one two and
one so that's under 500 by half a game
yeah but you're still Billy win some
lose some Billy win some lose some Wishy
wasy Bill Oh Billy Whiskers um I think
I'm still steady I think I'm like nine
games over nine and a something like
eight and a half nine but you're eight
games over I'm like yeah I'm 23 15 and
two Paul you a suplex in the book well
dude October I just bent October over
and [__] it you know well you did that
two years in a row hey Paul H Paul
[__] Mr October Bill I'm a Fall Guy
I'm a guy 20 Paul you're 20 oh no I was
23 yeah you're 27 you're 27 uh 19 and
two 27 19 and Two Against the Spread
Paul who's doing that where is ESPN Paul
why haven't they hired you the best
25 and
two yeah 1925 and two Paul what are you
talking about I knew I was way under
what do you mean he's not no what yeah
bill was through week 11 bill was 1821
and one two weeks ago he went one two
and one and last week he went one two
and one again right one two and one both
weeks you just said no only one week no
what was last week he was two and two
last week I I was three and one last
week yeah he was three and one the last
week don't you take away by three in one
God damn you Andrew all right so yeah so
you're 192 so you're
22 uh 24 and one so Paul's right Paul's
paying attention two and a half games
back yeah I know what Greek hey I know
what Greek I'm listening to on this
podcast now um all right guys there you
go enjoy week 14 and uh we'll see you
next week for week 15 it's so s take the
snake 4 and0 baby let's see nobody's
ever gone 4 and0 two times in a row no
no dude Jake The Snake could make
history he can make history The Whole
World's watching Jake all right I'll see
you guys thank you so much for watching
all right take care man